[Laughter]
hey what's going on yeah sorry i pushed
the button like a little early but
my finger just went blah like on the
[ __ ] mouse uh so yeah we were just
sitting here talking about how maybe we
would go see
the fire starter movie tomorrow and then
i see that danny rolling ghost faces
already said that it sucked ass look at
this [ __ ] look sure so she was looking
at the fan and now she's looking at me
what's the matter pokemon she's gonna
wind the fan on oh that's right you
forgot to turn the fan on she's like
what the hell is going on she was
looking at the fan and she's looking at
me
[Laughter]
why didn't daddy turn the fan on she
always turns the fan on when she's all
she knows all the routines
yeah
she could run this place
if she had hands she could run this if
she had hands she could run she has
hands just not thumbs up
if she knew how to use a computer
she does i'm turning i turn around and
she's on the floor playing with that
little mouse
and she's looking at me like i did
something wrong and then she looks up at
the fan and then looks back at me
and i'm like what and then she's looking
back up at the fan because it's not
moving i'm gonna turn it on now she's
okay she's like all right thank you she
tells you when to fill up trays and
everything she'll walk by an empty plate
and she'll be looking at it she'll point
at it with her nose and look at you put
some food in that
and then you put it and she goes okay
and walks off
she's [ __ ] hilarious it's like thank
you everything is copacetic yeah and she
demands to go in the closet at least
three times a day
yeah it wants to go in the closet just
crazy and she doesn't do anything well
she just looks in and goes okay i guess
there's nothing in here and then she
comes back out she does that with this
closet too yeah then she walks in there
and she's like what the [ __ ] i thought i
said it was cool in here but it never is
yeah so it's friday
it's friday the 13th friday the 13th
this is the friday the 13th show
go ahead and uh get your drink going
and we will hang out for at least a few
hours tonight
yeah it should be fun and we'll talk
about current events or talk about any
cases you guys have questions about we
can talk about paranormal stuff
talk about anything
talk about movies
we kind of like open lines open lines
and um we're presented with art bell
it's kind of like our bell open line
open lines open lines friday
they did that [ __ ] because they didn't
want to prepare for the [ __ ] show
well it is easy that's just friday i
mean just let it run well yeah and it's
like because remember we used to do the
main show on friday night and then we
did sidetracks on wednesday and then we
decided to switch it and honestly i
think i like that better because even
though it does front load my week with a
lot of work because i have to do like
all the research for all the movie
reviews and then i have to do the
research for the show i don't have as
much time get it over with though but
it's all yeah it's all over with so like
thursday and friday and saturday are
like easier because i don't have to do
like a bunch of research and stuff cable
company came in today and they put in
another wi-fi up here so we got yeah we
have i have to run the damn cable i have
i have a modem like thing like right
there the house has two of them one for
the top floor one for the bottom floor
the guy just came in he said he might uh
he asked about because i guess he does
game streaming yeah so he was like
asking about ours and he's like oh maybe
i'll come by so i don't know he said all
right
in the chat like and say hey i'm the
cable guy you know what i mean but yeah
so well i mean it's cool because
so all the [ __ ] that we have like online
up here the connection will be better
and we don't have to like have that long
ass
uh ethernet cable going all the way like
down the stairs like every time we were
gonna do a show we always like
threw it down the stairs and like took
it across the living room and [ __ ] like
that that's why i had to buy that
hundred foot one which was only fifteen
dollars it's not that big a deal i still
have it hooked up but now it's like all
hundred feet of it is just balled up
underneath the desk because the thing is
right there so that's like pretty handy
asks a good question he says tom when
are you going to put together the polar
lights enterprise together and hang it
in the background yeah i got you that
like a long time ago let me tell the
story i ordered the paint for it oh
that's right and the and the paint is
still yet to be delivered the paint came
from [ __ ] japan
i got pissed it was about eighty dollars
worth of paint
tatamia [ __ ] paint for it and all
that paint got thrown out of the [ __ ]
um train over there in la coming off
that dock because they showed that on
the news that there's a certain part of
the railroad tracks where they raid the
trains it's still on my amazon list and
it's going to be delivered any day
that's been [ __ ] months well have
they charged you for it though yes they
charged me
they charged me and there's no
button to ask for my refund well i guess
because you waited too long no no as it
was happening it never appeared i got
[ __ ]
bezos went on [ __ ] went on gear got
big and now he's trying to [ __ ] me
that's what jeff bezos jeff bezos was
nerdy [ __ ] and now he's big
because he's [ __ ] on those yachts
with those [ __ ] hotties and he wants
to go on hrt and do [ __ ] steroids and
he wants to [ __ ] he's trying to [ __ ]
me
yeah over dollars over 80 dollars
yeah sounds legit so i got mad i got
i got mad but it's a mint new in the box
polar lights
[ __ ] starship enterprise and then i'm
looking at this other stuff you can get
like a hundred dollars worth of [ __ ]
electronic upgrades through that through
the aftermarket to make the damn the
cells [ __ ] spin
with a remote control for all the with
the new ecm or ecu in there with [ __ ]
hundreds of hours of [ __ ]
recordings and music uh they got one of
one of the kits you can [ __ ] tell it
to do things that it'll fire real laser
beams out of the [ __ ] top and the
bottom of the face
they have all this [ __ ] and you know
hopefully it's just on stun here's the
thing though if if the phasers fire out
a real laser you're just going to see a
dot on the floor
you know what i mean you won't see the
beam and then pokey'll chase yeah but uh
[Laughter]
those in the cells look pretty cool
because they give the spin
and the ones that come with just kind of
they're just kind of like glowing
lights
but i think for about 80 bucks you can
hook it up so they actually [ __ ] spin
like they did on the and that was really
cool there's a couple different versions
of those
and
uh just as that that particular kit had
a lot of upgrades to it and i'm i was
thinking man if i'm gonna [ __ ] build
this thing
i ought to really [ __ ] build it yeah
i mean i spent a lot of money on that
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it's it's over a hundred dollars to
that kid but 150 probably i think for
that it was something like that 150 well
it was like really hard to find because
well they have it wasn't so much that
hard to find it's just hard to wait
because they have you know how trekkies
are
and i'm not hating like because i love
the original series too but
they have really detailed models of like
every iteration you have all of the
enterprise and the shuttlecrafts and
just like every single thing that was on
star trek they have a model of that yeah
so you always have to like make sure
that you get like the right one because
it's like no that's the one that from
[ __ ] star trek enterprise and that's
the one from next generation you have to
make sure you get like the [ __ ] this
is the one from the original series yes
this is kirk's old one from the show
now my other enterprise that i liked was
the one from um
uh uh [ __ ] uh star trek the motion
picture
and then there's another one right after
that in the next movie because i think
the from the one from motion pitcher i
think that one got destroyed or it got
it got destroyed in the wrath of con or
i don't there was two of them in that
one
from i don't remember exactly what
happened but that one from um
that one from uh
motion pitcher and rathika and that was
a good one
that was a good [ __ ] enterprise way
it looked remember when i first saw it
as a kid i thought it looked funny
because it didn't look like the one from
the tv show but it grew on me
same thing with the [ __ ] klingon
katengas i think they're called katenga
[ __ ] battle cruisers those those
always look good
i like the one from the original show
and i like the one from uh the movies
i was actually gonna get you both things
because you know i was gonna get you
that one too but yeah it was like once i
saw how expensive the enterprise one was
i'm like oh i can't afford to get two of
them but i was originally planted
against you yeah that's like i'm not
[ __ ] i'm not [ __ ] money back the
battle cruisers are good
yeah it did look cool but maybe maybe
next year maybe one maybe for your
birthday i built one when i was a kid
they were cheaper back then i don't
think they were quite as big i think it
was only about that big
i had one from the motion picture
and um
i think they were only about 15 bucks
which was kind of a lot of money in the
early 80s i think in the late 70s early
80s that bought that one pretty
yeah they were real simple they were
mostly something you just painted
yeah i painted the [ __ ] out of them when
i was kid i had my vision of course was
really good in your high hand
coordination is really good when you're
a kid you i could paint the tiny little
eyeballs on those dungeons and dragons
lead figurines you know little orcs and
kobolds and [ __ ] i could [ __ ]
paint eyes and face i could do that
until i was about 37 or 38 years old and
then you lose kind of the ability to
produce everything
magnifying glass actually no i think i
could do that until i was about 45. yeah
now that i'm thinking about it and then
my eyesight just went to [ __ ] like in
about a six month period it was amazing
but yeah i always had like really good
vision until like suddenly
um
yeah i've been enjoying star trek
strange new worlds
speaking of sci-fi i know i'm late to
this says john smith but has anyone else
seen the expanse i just started and
really liking it didn't did we start
watching that or am i totally crazy and
i'm thinking of something else i know
that that's been everywhere yeah i know
that it's been like recommended to it
was the one that we were that we watched
that we liked
[ __ ] man we watch so much stuff that
it's like i can't and sometimes we start
things and then like we get distracted
and start watching other things and then
i forget to go back to the other stuff
like i said there's just so much
i mean there's so much decent
entertainment out that it's hard to keep
up with all of it you know that's right
sabrina gets it right kirk destroyed
that ship and the search was spock
that's right that's when it got
destroyed
yeah
yeah wrath of khan scared the crap out
of me as a kid to the creature in the
ear sequence yeah that wigged me out
when i was a kid too because i was all
up and i was all about like um creeped
out by urban legends and there's an
urban legend about like earwigs and
stuff like that and yeah that like wigs
me out also
some people didn't like uh
the the first one the motion picture i
loved it as a kid i like we should check
and see when fathom events are doing
that on the big screen because i would
like to see that on the big screen
because i never got to
there was a lot behind the scenes that a
lot of people who are like non-trekkies
at the time i didn't know but i found
out later
they they were gonna make a new star
trek series called a phase two star trek
phase two
and they had merged a lot of the cast
from from that proposed series and a lot
of the ideas from that series into star
trek the motion picture that's why uh
that young the young guy who's supposed
to be a replacement for for kirk he kind
of sacrificed himself to stay with the
[ __ ] veger and the bald headed girl
and [ __ ] they were gonna they were like
the leads of that proposed series that
they never made it though
uh and then
a lot of phase two ended up kind of
being rebooted
really it seemed like it was forever
when i was a kid but it was rebooted
into the next generation it seemed like
it was forever but it was like really
only like seven years i think it's seven
eight years
i think what do you remember when that
was what year was that um
i think
star trek the motion
[ __ ]
next generation came out when
eighty uh
four
eighty five maybe
that's right i thought it was like mid
to late eighties but i was immediately
off on that when you think about it it
was only like five or six years later
that that came out it was you know even
though it seemed like a long time it
seemed like a long time when you were a
kid but it wasn't that long it did
so
phase two became next generation fourth
renown says 87 maybe
i was thinking like 86 but yeah i just i
didn't want to say because i'm not i
absolutely i'm not sure the motion
picture came out i think in 78 yeah it
was 87 says
87 yeah and and motion picture i think
came out in 78 79 i think it's around
that time it was after star trek
i think it might have been 78.79 maybe i
thought it was early 80s like i thought
it was 81 but i could be wrong about
that too late
70s i remember
but yeah
i mean you know okay
yeah when did the original like star
trek the motion picture come out i think
it was yeah late 70s
i think that's why i remembered it i
thought it was early 80s but like i said
i'm only a few years but from i'm
willing to concede that i could be
totally the point of view of a kid it
was forever
well yeah when you're a kid everything
seems like oh my god it's like it's
eight months until christmas oh my god
like it seemed like forever and now i'm
just like holy [ __ ] it's already [ __ ]
79 okay so i was right it was about
70 years later yeah and that's what
happened to uh that's what happened to
uh phased star trek phase two
dj maniac said uh check your dms i sent
you pics of my custom nicholas cage
action figure from mandy about an hour
ago all right oh [ __ ] i'm gonna have to
check that out i don't know if he sent
it to you or if he sent it to me he
might have sent it to like the 13
o'clock
show which is which is on my thing but
uh yeah late 70s from rush picture yeah
for some reason i thought it was like 8
1980 but you know i wasn't that far off
i guess
and let's see what was i going to say
somebody asked me um the show that we
were talking about could have been
killjoys now it wasn't that um what the
[ __ ] was it
i can't remember so like it was a sci-fi
series and we started watching it but it
was good but then we got like distracted
by something else honestly if i don't
watch like an entire series
like in a night or two i'll probably
just like forget and like watch
something else instead unless i'm like
really really into it i just have like
really i don't know why i do that but
i mean because like like last night
check it out i go to shutter
because thursday nights they usually add
new episodes of cursed films
but i notice that i guess the season is
over of curse film season two or season
three or whatever it is because the one
that the last one was on there's
cannibal holocaust and i saw that one
last week so i was like okay well i
guess that season is over but then i
noticed that shutter had also added
season three of eli roth's history of
horror and i was like oh well there's my
evening sorted so i just sat there and
watched every single episode i think it
was
what was it i think it was six episodes
and they were each about 45 minutes long
i really really like that series to be
honest with you it's not they can't do
like a lot with it because it was
originally on amc i guess
um because i think i watched the first
season on amc but now blake shutter has
all of them on there
but the ones they did last night
were actually really good they had the
first one was uh sequels that don't suck
and then they had one about
psychics they had one about infections
they had one about apocalyptic horror
they had one about um
what were the other ones
and
i'll think of it in a second they had
like two more
holiday horror that was one not
necessarily it was all holidays they
talked about my bloody valentine and
silent night deadly night and all that
kind of april fool's day and all that
kind of stuff and
mad scientist i think that was the other
one that was a good one too but yeah
that's a good show they get like a lot
of people like to come in there and like
talk on that so i was really into that
uh it's on your personal one okay so
all right we'll we'll find out we'll
find out we'll see it we'll see it yeah
cannibal holocaust this week see but i
saw that one last that i saw that last
thursday though so i think that was the
last one i think that was the last one
but that's a good that's a good uh
series curse films i kind of feel like
they went a little bit
i mean there really aren't that many
horror movies that said they had like a
cursed set where like people actually
like [ __ ] died and stuff like they
did but
i don't think there's like enough but
it's interesting in its own right i said
they just kind of went the direction of
well we're going to talk about sort of
iconic
cult films horror films that had like
really troubled productions
um and that's fine with me you know what
i'm saying so when they talked about
cannibal holocaust they talked about
obviously like um
uh
like uh what's his [ __ ] name
what's his [ __ ] name
about him getting like dragged in for
you know he killed the actors like it's
a snuff film and [ __ ] like that so they
did that and then they also did this
season they did one on rosemary's baby
where they talked a lot about the sharon
tate murders and
all that other kind of stuff and
honestly the guy talked about they
talked about on the rosemary's baby one
they talked about a lot of other murders
that had taken place in the same
area like in that um canyon like where
sharon tate and them lived and that was
actually really interesting because i
hadn't heard of a lot of those and i was
like that might make a good show like
all the murders other than the manson
murders that took place in that same
area like all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
happened it wasn't just murders it was
like suicides and like other kind of
crazy [ __ ] too but yeah that was like
really interesting
um
murder hornet mexican marine was ready
to shoot me oh my goodness okay well
i want to do a horror film called arbor
day about a killer tree i'm you know
what i'm amazed that that hasn't been
done i mean i kind of feel like
somebody must have made an arbor day
horror movie
somebody must have go let's go check to
be right now and see if there's got to
be an arbor day horror movie about a
killer drink there there absolutely has
to be
but yeah the the holiday one they kind
of talked about it's kind of good
because they only have 45 minutes so
what they usually do is they'll kind of
like skim over and like show you
examples but then they'll kind of like
focus on four or five like for a longer
period of time so on this one they
talked about
halloween at first and then they talked
about
mother's day
which is funny because brandon tunnell
just did a
show about that then they talked about
april fool's day which is one of my
favorites from the 80s then they talked
about
silent night deadly night and they
talked about black christmas
and
they talked about terror train because
that one happened on new year's i think
we like reviewed that one not too long
ago
but then they kind of went into like all
the other oh and they talked about my
bloody valentine if i didn't say that
which is that's a great [ __ ] movie we
use 2b daily to be
i have to say i mean they have
everything like i always check that
first because even though they have like
a few commercials and stuff
they have a massive
library i don't know how they [ __ ]
manage it
but
especially horror movies and like they
have a [ __ ] ton of other stuff too it's
just like tv series and [ __ ] like that i
always check that first because
90 of the time like 2b will probably
have it like the movie that i'm looking
for like not always but
they have so much stuff in fact the only
thing that i will complain about with 2b
is that
their
the search function i mean unless you
know exactly what you're looking for
you really gotta wade through a bunch of
stuff because it i mean it's you just go
to the category horror and there's like
40 bajillion movies they're not
alphabetical they're not like in sub
genres
nothing like they're not you know by
year or anything like that so it's just
kind of like you just have to skim
through until you find what you want
like i said unless you're looking for
something like specific so it is kind of
a pain when you're just kind of trying
to scroll through and find something to
watch but you know
blairdo was saying that he saw the uh
the phase two star trek phase two didn't
look too good
uh
based on the down photos of the sets and
stuff
i don't remember all the
the details about phase two
but if i remember correctly they didn't
shoot anything for phase two
they were phase two is kind of like just
in a development kind of like in
development hell in a certain way
and um
i think they started to make certain
things for it but i don't think it was
i think it was kind of more like uh
concept type stuff to get the money
together
and then once they kind of had money
together they realized that that the
money might be better spent if they
actually just made a star trek movie
they might get a better return on it
paramount had something to do with it
so
all the money
started to get diverted away from that
project and it went into the motion
picture
and uh evidently they had some contracts
or something with certain people that
were
going to be cast for for uh phase two
and they kind of
it kind of behooved paramount to put
them in the movie too and now they kind
of had two casts
two casts of the enterprise that they
have now have to write into it
and uh but they kind of wrote a story
around that you know
and uh the movie was profitable enough
to where doing movies was more
was better than um
doing a series
but uh then evidently it kind of came
back around they said you know what this
is a big enough franchise where we could
do a series and have movies
you know so i guess the the movies kind
of revived interested in in in star trek
and um
when they when they went to next
generation a lot of the ideas
that started off next generation
actually kind of came from phase two
um
but you know i'll be honest i i don't
really like next i mean some people like
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] you talking
about they fell into star trek because
the next generation
i wasn't a big fan of next generation
i mean i i watched the whole thing i
would say
they had the first two seasons were
[ __ ] really bad
um
you didn't really know they were bad
because you were a kid and they were
kind of
you were kind of starved from seeing it
but it's almost kind of incoherent weird
[ __ ] happened
everything was like a standalone
later when it really started to pull
together it got a little bit better but
then it became real soapy
and
it kind of lost me although they had
some really good seasons especially when
all the borg stuff started to come in
they had some stuff with the klingons
start you know the way that you know
some of the [ __ ] that they were going
that they were going through some of
that was good
but it
it was kind of very
commercial you always knew that jordy
was going to get him out of it somehow i
just
got kind of stale if you ask me
one of my favorite star trek
programs was like one of the least
popular and that's enterprise
with scott bakula and those guys and
[ __ ] to paul and [ __ ] trip i i
like that that series because
they didn't have any technology and they
had real good
real good [ __ ] characters like
[ __ ] shran
and you know there were aliens they had
really good aliens that were regulars on
there
and uh dude who praised strand [ __ ]
knocked it out of the park that's uh
same guy who did herbert west uh jeffrey
jeffrey combs
he was actually on the on the eli raw
thing i was talking they were talking
about on the psychics episode they were
talking about the frighteners they did
like a big long segment on that yeah and
uh so they actually interviewed uh
jeffrey combs about that i would watch a
whole [ __ ] motion picture of a whole
series about shran
and the endurance i would as well i
would just just show you but jeffrey
combs got to do it jeffrey combs in it
how [ __ ] he was
left the service and became a damn
criminal and a mercenary but he still
had to save his daughter and that [ __ ]
went down and
an enterprise the enterprise series had
two of the best mirror episodes of all
times
there towards the end of the series but
you the average person wouldn't
understand how good those mirror
episodes were unless they knew those
characters because they were all totally
opposite
and you know tear an empire [ __ ] you
know just [ __ ] great series just took
a couple seasons for it to get rolling
then once it really started to get
rolling then it it went on for a season
or two and then it got cancelled
just upn
upn kind of
they didn't
and it seems like every time star wars
star trek comes back
it takes a couple seasons for it to get
rolling now they were talking about this
new cursement trick or whatever this
[ __ ] going on at cbs now
um i've heard nothing but bad things
about it you know what the [ __ ]
just [ __ ] they did with [ __ ] uh oh
what's his name
little captain not riker but the other
guy camp a card
it just looks really lame i'm not i
don't want to ruin my memories of star
trek
the best best new star trek is star trek
continues man [ __ ] which is
you know
fan made
and that's just just like going back the
final [ __ ] the final season of the
old episodes of kirk and spock and you
guys you got [ __ ]
made with love man just a real good
uh real good
final season
john smith says i love april fool's day
but that would be the end of a
friendship if someone played that trick
on me same um and i know that some
people they even talked about this on
the show when they were talking about uh
april fool's day is that i know some
people didn't like now spoiler alert for
a movie from 1985 or 1986 or whatever it
was uh it's a slasher but nobody
actually died at the end it was all like
a practical joke which you should have
seen coming because april fool's day but
um i didn't even mind that because i
think the thing that i liked the most
about it was the cast like i really like
it had a great [ __ ] cast and i really
liked the way that because yeah biff
tannen was in it a lot of people were in
it like um uh amy steele from friday 13
part two was in it [ __ ] tons of
people were in it the chick from
valley girl was in it all these people
were in it and they were like really
really good like interacting with each
other so i think that was like my
favorite part more than like even the
slasher stuff because it wasn't really
that
gory it had like a little bit of gore
but that's about it guys are showing
love for deep space nine every deep
space nine episode i saw i thought was
great but i was in the army when a lot
of that was happening and
or busy and i was never able to watch
the entire series but it
it looked really good too but i could
also tell it was going it got that one
was getting kind of soapy also
but at least it seemed like it was
but i imagine if you watch it from the
very beginning and watch it all the way
through you probably get
to get hung up on it um so i may if i
ever have time i'll go back and watch
that
um
and then i got some other people to talk
about that they were fans of shrand too
i don't know man [ __ ] i like shiran i
thought sram was one of the best
characters
of all of star trek up there with spock
you didn't get quite a get enough of
shrand
but it was enterprise it wasn't the
shrine show you know because i
understand he would just appear
to liven up the series every now and
then he'd have some hardcore [ __ ] he was
basically like general patton in space
or [ __ ] general zhukov or something
from the from the soviet army he was
like he was like something out of the
1940s
and uh [ __ ] jeffrey combs just
[ __ ] nailed it with that character he
did a lot of good characters deep space
nine and he'd always show up to save
star trek playing some kardashian
something or other or some one of these
jim hadar
[ __ ] and raising his damn
children out of pods and giving him
secret sauce and [ __ ] you guys know what
i'm talking about i don't remember the
name of all that stuff i'm not you know
anyway he would show up he would do a
great job but his shrine
and then he fell in love with this first
officer and she and the female andorians
are like all tall and all the
all the males are little short [ __ ]
like me and [ __ ] i [ __ ] like this
the males are all short and the women
were all tall
i thought that was really cool
and then uh
but then he takes him back to andor
indoria it's all the [ __ ] ice planet
and
boiling hot worms falling out of the ice
and just
yeah that was a good character i would
watch i don't know about you man you can
put it in the comment section
i would love to see an entire series
based around shran
i don't think he has a fan base but it
would a whole series basically i don't
know
i mean if they
honestly if they kind of like
targeted it toward yeah sci-fi like star
trek fans but also a little bit toward
horror fans as well you probably like
cause everybody loves jeffrey combs like
all the horror fans this is the problem
with some of the star trek they're
trying to replicate
starship enterprise with kirk a lot
because that's really the archetype
the problem with that is that he's human
why not do the whole thing where it's a
star trek episode where there are no
humans on it at all there's just none
it's just these andorians
all right with shran and his ship and
they're going to these [ __ ] up places
that humans wouldn't go to
and they're dealing with a corrupt
government it's making them do things
that they don't want to do because
that's that's really shreds trans whole
[ __ ] thing is there making me do this
i don't believe in it but they're making
me do it you know and that would have
been a great series
of kind of like almost like a mirror
episode of star trek or star trek where
you know
they got to do this spaceship stuff man
and it's not all that cool you know what
i mean [ __ ]
they somehow have to save the situation
even though the the guys in charge of
them are a bunch of [ __ ] corrupt
gangsters you know that'd be a great
series
i mean i think it would honestly like i
said if they did it more
again targeting to star trek fans but
also targeting toward like the horror
market a little bit
then you'd probably get like a wider
thing because like i said
jeffrey combs i kind of feel like him
and like
um
bruce campbell and like you know brad
dorff and there's all these like great
character actors that don't really get
appreciated in more mainstream films and
stuff like that but horror fans [ __ ]
love them yeah and i think that's like
pretty [ __ ] cool so they have like a
large fan base though i mean i think
sram would be great because you know
yeah sram would appeal to the guys that
liked kirk he'd be like kirk but he was
an alien yeah you know i'd watch that
yeah
i'm not gonna lie there's no reason to
have any humans in in the in the [ __ ]
series
because yeah human you want to put that
somewhere deep in space where humans
aren't
yeah i mean to just keep it interesting
you see humans every day
now the writers humans are boring yeah
but the writers would come well no we
got to have representation people have
to see themselves in these characters
and no they don't no they [ __ ] don't
if i'm gonna watch a [ __ ] samurai
movie there better not be any white
people in it you know what i mean i'm
gonna watch [ __ ] zatuichi you know
what i mean with [ __ ] katsushin
[ __ ] playing zatuichi that's what i
want to see i'm paying to see japan back
in the tokugawa period there's not going
to be any white people or black people
in that all right it's just me just
japanese people that's what i'm paying
to see well if i'm going to watch a
[ __ ] something about shrine on
another planet [ __ ] dude there better
not even be any humans in this
you don't come out i don't want to see a
single [ __ ] human
all right this we're on another planet
we're escaping from humans okay
and we can't stand these just stay over
there
exactly that was what was so good about
um the northmen there was no modern
people in the northmen
at all
normally when you have some [ __ ] about
rome or this and that it's basically
modern people in an ancient setting
northman took you into the [ __ ]
mentality
of these [ __ ] barbarian barbarians
basically what they were thinking
they're showing you what they're
thinking
you know valkyries and [ __ ] fights
between gods and [ __ ]
supernatural stuff happening
and i would imagine if you're a [ __ ]
viking berserker
you're you know your imagination
is a part of your reality you know i
mean you're
you probably can't really tell too much
between what you imagined and what what
really happened
so
because it was a spiritual world that
they were dealing with i just thought it
was great they transported me to that
time
you know i wasn't there to see myself in
any of this so this is just it was very
immersive it was yeah it was very and i
wanted to see them i didn't want to see
me
you know or people i know
i want to go to this other world it
depends on the story yeah it does depend
on the story
if the story is taking you away from
here it can't be like this place it's
got to be different
well we talked about this before how
some actors
just have a look where they can't play
period pieces yeah like because they
don't like you don't buy that they're
from that era no matter what they do
like no matter what clothes they put
them in or whatever haircut they give
them like sometimes you still know that
that's a modern person and i don't i
don't even know why that is
um i can't really put my finger on it i
think that was maybe one of the problems
well one of the problems
um with like for example like keanu
reeves in the dracula movie um you know
not just modern not just the accent but
he just always strikes me as a modern
person
like
you know what i mean and that's no dig
on like actors like some actors have
strengths and weakness weaknesses some
people can play
like hey i'm from the 16th century and
you buy it some people just can't
you know they just look too modern or
there's something about their whole
aura
that just is
is just saying that i am not really a
person from this like ancient time
period you know what i'm saying so it's
kind of hard to get right but yeah they
well i mean the north man they did a
really good job with that because all of
those people i kind of forgot
that
i mean they're yeah like i knew they
were actors because some of them were
recognizable like ethan hawk and uh and
nicole kidman and stuff but
you know and anya taylor joy
and i recognize them but you kind of
forgot that they were actors like you
kind of got so into it because they
looked like they were from that era from
that time period you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah holy person says yeah
humans are predictable yeah they're
predictable and you understand
how they're going to react and how
they're going to imagine things if you
had a series where it's just nothing but
hondurans on there and shrine
they'd be they're going to be able to do
some things here like what the [ __ ]
because they have their own
their own legends and their own culture
and their own their own sense of
morality and why they're like this
and you the audience needs to see that
and be immersed in that type of thing a
totally alternate
perception of reality you know that's a
lot more fun
i mean it's still going to be
human-centric because humans wrote it
obviously but
you know right around but yeah you can
have a lot of fun with that because you
can just kind of like go hog wild yeah
because there was some [ __ ] where in
that particular series with enterprise
with shran
[ __ ]
archer who's the cabin of the enterprise
finds out that there's a relationship
going on between shrine and the first
officer who's a
white-haired [ __ ] blue chick with
antennas who's probably about almost
nearly a foot taller than another foot
but probably about a good eight inches
taller than him and he's like so this is
allowed and he goes i couldn't resist
you know
it was just i couldn't say no what do
you mean he goes you don't understand
how it is with us you know what i mean
it's not possible yeah i think he said
for my own safety i couldn't
say no so basically what you're finding
out is that
she raped him
she's like a praying mantis yeah yeah
they're like jumped on him and then said
it's like it's like the praying mantis
that you have
if she chooses you yours there's no
choice
because uh you know she might kill you
if you if you uh and but he did he did
love her though but that's uh evidently
kind of
violence happened first and then you
kind of bond with them and then which
that was like a trip because the rest of
it was uh
pretty human
but then you find out that [ __ ] was
backwards or which i thought that was a
[ __ ] nice touch where no the men were
not the aggressors in these
relationships the females were
you know
he didn't look like it though
because he's ordering around she's a
subordinate but that's only the rank
that's not the biology right and the
biology of the species it was uh you
know the women were in charge of that
kind of [ __ ]
you know you couldn't say no
or you're taking your life into your
hands you know
they might retaliate
that's pretty funny yeah
uh bluetooth dude says hopefully the
shuttle pod one enterprise podcast
youtube show will have jeffrey combs on
it in the future i mean he seemed pretty
open to being on because he likes to go
on shows yeah and like i said he was on
the the eli roth one like i said he was
talking about the frighteners oh it
cracks me up because we saw him live on
the one where the dude had the resonator
yeah that's right the resonator yeah he
was like he was super anticipated he was
just casting from his house he was uh he
was yeah like guessing on a podcast like
like a size of ours
and cones was drinking he he drinks man
he gets [ __ ] loaded he was having a
good time he was he was kind of hiding
the fact that he was drinking but you
knew and he was like excuse me one
second i'll be back he's going to take a
leak
and uh the thing about combs is that
he's really talented and really
knowledgeable about about literature and
[ __ ] poe and the man behind these
stories and
he's uh he's he's the kind of guy where
you could uh
drink with and [ __ ] talk about that
[ __ ] forever nerd out as long as it's
kind of an elevated nerd at nerding out
he likes
he likes people do that because he was
doing a live po show yeah
and um but he also said uh he kind of
combs gave me that watching that show
comes gave me the idea for a shrand show
because he said he loved doing that
character and that maybe one day you
might see charan come back because he's
like to do sran again i was thinking boy
it'd be great to do a have a whole
[ __ ] series which kevin schrandt that
would be great yeah captain tran on his
ship and then get on it somebody call
jeffrey combs up yeah
and find out who he had to find out who
owns that property and
probably upn
and then how do you get the licensing
for it and each version of star trek is
its own property and different
different channels and different
companies own those properties there
can't be a whole lot of crossover or you
got to pay royalties that's why some of
the new star trek if you ask me sucks it
doesn't look like any other star trek
it's just kind of like a generic
space movies you know
yeah sometimes they have to like work
around
they don't have certain rights for
certain things yeah
and um
now that
there's a new one that's going to have
pyke on it somebody was mentioning it
was a brave new world
i know people had [ __ ] high hopes for
it but
other reviewers that i've seen it was
like now they instantly didn't like it
uh and you know they they kind of like
the classic stuff that i that i like
but uh
i'd have to let that go for a couple
seasons before i want to
watch it and invest in it there's so
many other things to watch i've got i've
just i just rented i just got brit box
i'm watching the old doctor who's the
[ __ ] tom baker in a man
watching that old [ __ ] [ __ ] stagey
theatrical low budget [ __ ]
kind of brings me back to where man at
least they could write back then they
could write and they were classically
trained actors and they're being stagey
in performances but they have to because
there's no special effects to speak of
no real budget so you have to put on a
show
there's
some about that's kind of charming you
know
i gotta dig through there and see what
they got yeah on brick box adriana says
jenny that deadbringer t-shirt is
awesome thank you uh yeah i actually
made this um
i want to make like a better version i
just made like a one-off because i
wanted one
and i was like i don't know if anybody
else would want one so uh but yeah i
just made one and i was like i don't
know there's some things about it i
don't like but
because you know when when i design
things for myself
when i design things for other people it
doesn't really take me that long because
i kind of feel like oh they probably
want this that and the other thing and i
do it but when i design things for my
own self like if like it took me you
don't even know when we first started
the 13 o'clock show
um it took me like
[ __ ] ages like i redid the logo i
redid like all the artwork for the
channels like a million times because i
would do it and i'd be like okay i'm
happy with that and then the next day
i'd look at it maybe i don't like it and
then i'd have to start all over i don't
know why i do i don't know so if it's
something for me it's like i get super
picky but yeah so
i like this shirt but i think i could do
like a better one so initially so later
i'm going to do a better one
granthars has some random questions
how many normies have you converted into
goths oh [ __ ]
how converting armies yeah we i don't
think we have actually yeah
i'm kind of like it's not really a
conversion thing
but i mean if they want to get into it
they can get into it i'm not like
[ __ ] babysitting they're holding
their hand or nothing i don't that's i
can't think of anybody i can't think of
anybody
um
name your favorite porn star and why oh
this all i'll show i'll jump that one
over too
to tom in a minute although
i quite like uh belladonna i know that's
like an easy thing to say because she's
famous and she's got like
lines of uh sex toys and [ __ ] like that
and all i don't know there's just
something i like her i like the little
gap between her teeth she just seems
like a cool and she seems like she's
having a good time which like i said
a lot of porn stars don't seem like
they're they don't really seem like
they're having that that good of time or
you know they're just like yeah here we
go but she seems like she's like really
into it i don't know um name one person
dead or alive he would spend 10 years
with
on a deserted island ugh
i don't know i don't know if i could
think of a person who who do i like
enough
to spend 10 years with on a deserted
island without me like just drowning
them
probably nobody
[Laughter]
i get sick i would definitely get sick
of pretty much any even the coolest
person would like to start to get on my
nerves after 10 i'm just like maybe i
could just like push them off a cliff or
something
and then the sequels would eat them
i know that's terrible but yeah i'm like
really impatient
like i like people a lot like at first
but then like after a while like if i'm
you know a round of like if if i don't
have like any way to get away from them
or if i'm like around them a long time
then i'll just be like i think i might
want to kill this person it's yeah it's
it goes like that
um cones yeah we were talking about that
earlier yeah he did um all those he went
around uh jeffrey combs went around
doing uh stage plays as edgar allan poe
and i've seen like parts of it i never
seen it live unfortunately but i've seen
um a lot of stuff on youtube and he was
like um you know talking about it like
he had different uh interviews about it
and he seems like really into that and
it's like it's really cool i really like
that and honestly he's been in a lot of
he seems like he's really into lovecraft
too because
wasn't he in that movie what the [ __ ]
was that movie called where he played
did he actually play hp lovecraft or
like an hp lovecraft
surrogate type
what the [ __ ] was that thing called i
can't remember we saw it like not too
long ago and i think i have it like on
dvd but he seems like really cool when
we were watching the um or when i was
watching rather because tom didn't watch
it he was just like farting around other
parts of the house but
i was watching that eli roth thing uh
history of horror and they were talking
about the frighteners and apparently it
was jeffrey combs's idea
for his character to have hitler hair
in that and he's like
uh you know he's like well you know when
i was getting into like my character and
everything and he was like oh he's super
authoritarian and stuff he's like who's
like the main like most authoritarian oh
uh i know and so he found this book
about hitler about world war ii or
whatever and he saw a picture of hitler
was like as a young person and so like
he goes to peter jackson who directed it
and he's like hey i want to do my hair
like this what do you think about it
he's like expecting peter jackson to go
no don't do that but he's like the
funniest thing to be was that jeffrey
combs like says yeah peter jackson just
looks at the picture and there was like
a big pause and then jeffrey combs did a
new zealand accent and he's like yeah
yeah that'd be good
and it just like made me laugh like
really hard that jeffrey cove
was talking like peter jackson i don't
know why that made me laugh so hard but
it really did so he could have like the
[ __ ] hitler hair he was [ __ ] crazy
in that movie
um yeah jeffrey comes quote says danny
rolly goes face what's the matter
somebody piss on your hush puppies
i've heard somebody pissing your corn
flakes or somebody poop on your birthday
cake i've heard those ones before but
i've never heard pissing on your hush
puppies before
um oracle said a friend of mine saw him
in the po play
that's cool that's one i would have
really liked to have seen that actually
because from what i saw like on youtube
and [ __ ] like that um
it looked really cool
because i don't know he just seems like
a cool dude and i love edgar allan poe
so you know
um okay jenny dude those across the
river by christopher buellman for the
next homes of terry won't be
disappointed okay
i will tell you though that i started
reading not that book but i started
reading another christopher bielman book
and
i dnf'd it i i was like reading it
because i was going to review it and
then i was just like i'm just really not
into this at all
and i felt really bad because i know it
was probably you and i know that you
like recommended it but i will try that
one out i promise but like the one that
i can't remember what it was called now
because it was a while back but i did
start reading one of his books and i was
just kind of like man i just i just i
don't know why i just couldn't get into
it maybe it was my mood i don't know
what it was but i don't know but i'll
try to read that one later but honestly
i just i just bought
a bunch of books
um
so i just bought
like two or three books
i bought two books at barnes noble like
last week and then i ordered two i got a
simple plan by scott smith he was he's
the same guy that wrote the ruins
obviously but
he's only written two novels the ruins
and
a simple plan which obviously was made
into a movie by sam raimi like back in
the 90s and i've seen the movie and it's
excellent but everybody tells me like
the book is like the best [ __ ] book
ever so i was like okay i'll buy it
whatever um so i bought that and i
bought another grady hendrix book and i
bought another stephen graham jones book
and i bought one
that's like a short story collection i
don't even remember where i heard about
it but somebody told me
i can't remember what's what is it
called the melancholy of anatomy or
something like that and like somebody
told me about it and said this is like
weird as [ __ ] like all the uh these
short stories and i was like i kind of
read the synopsis and i was like ooh
that sounds like really bizarre and like
right up my alley so i ordered that as
well so
those might be the ones for the next
month i'm not really sure because i'm
still working my way through
all these ones that i checked out on
kindle unlimited like the next one i'm
gonna do is another gemma moore one
because i already read that and i
recorded the review for it today that
was like a novella
so
and then i'm looking at my calendar
i have a couple other books in there but
i can change them around
i don't know i'll give that one a look
oscar i promise but i did start reading
one by that author before and i couldn't
get into it
and i can't put my finger on why i
couldn't get into it i just couldn't get
into it but maybe that one's different
it wasn't that one it was a different
one so jenny and i we're looking forward
to seeing the new fire starter
and as soon as we start the [ __ ]
stream who was it somebody jumps in the
street he jumps in the there's danny
really good danny jumps in the [ __ ]
into the comment section and goes oh by
the way fire starter sucked i was like
god damn it i am
you know now we don't get to go to the
movies tomorrow i don't know
maybe it sucked maybe it didn't suck i
don't know
why are you she always wants to go on a
saturday yeah but saturday is really the
one of the only days that i don't have
anything else going on that's why yeah
saturday or thursdays are good too you
and a million other [ __ ] down
there well that's what i mean that's
what i'm saying
we don't have to i mean we can go
some other time i hate that some other
time
much rather go during the weekday
i hate that place on the we on the
weekends it's just [ __ ]
the traffic's bad and it's [ __ ]
packed
you know when i go i want to go eat some
lunch
yeah i know but
well we'll have to go someday when
we go monday
i know but then we have to be back
before six so we can stream you know
what i'm saying we'll be back before six
yeah i guess we could do that yeah we're
always back before sex it's just you
know like i said weekdays
weekdays are hard because a lot of times
like i get because everybody else is
working so they send me
jobs and [ __ ] so you know we can always
just make them wait
will you make everybody wait
bring back the 13 o'clock green screen
honestly we only did that for like
whatever happened to that green screen
thing did you just throw it out yeah
longer
i mean you know i forgot that we did
that
we tried to do it for a little while but
it didn't quite work yeah yeah well the
thing about greens if you have the green
screen you have to light it
perfectly perfectly and like [ __ ]
flat yeah so it has to be to like to get
it to because otherwise you get folds
and then like and it requires a lot of
[ __ ] data to do green screen if you
don't have a powerful [ __ ] computer
to really start well i could do it now
you could do it now but back then but
back then i didn't really have time to
livestream green greens green scream i
don't know maybe we have enough but
well now that this connection you notice
we haven't had problems because now
connections are hardwired now no no
wireless
i told him about it when he first showed
up the technician was oh yeah
streaming wireless through there he's
looking a lot of data gets backed up
well i mean most places will tell you
like if you're streaming uh if if at all
possible you should actually like do
like not just wi-fi you really need to
have like a connection yeah so a
physical connection because that will
help you a lot even though they seem to
be able to do it pretty well through
cell phones well i mean yeah so like
people like hot spots yeah i mean
you know
that's the thing like i guess dan like
dan bell he always does his saturday
night shows and he just streams those
through his phone
but he's in a big city baltimore and he
has like a really really nice like
he has like the latest iteration of the
iphone so i'm imagining that that's
probably like a really [ __ ] expensive
service probably probably helps price
pays extra has a wi-fi hotspot set up
and [ __ ] yeah i mean because that's kind
of his that's his uh bread and butter
that's his career so yeah you have to
like pay for
the guy that the guy the technician that
was here like installing the other
uh
our other modem yeah came in it was like
he was talking about doing stuff in
adobe after effects and he's like yeah
you got to pay like 20 a month for that
and i'm like dude i'm like i'm a graphic
designer like you have to pay
um i can't like how much is it all
together because i don't do the whole
adobe package but yeah you have to pay
they went to a monthly thing
remember back like back in the wool you
don't remember but like back in the old
days before um adobe went to monthly
[ __ ] for photoshop and illustrator and
indesign and all that and premiere
um to buy the whole package
i think
was 700
800 something like that it was like some
ridiculous amount
so
obviously um i couldn't afford that so i
pirated it because um [ __ ] man i didn't
have like [ __ ] 700 to spend on that
[ __ ]
so
i mean nowadays it's i guess it's kind
of better even though in the long run
you pay more for it because you're
paying don't do it because you're paying
um
monthly but you can only you can you
don't have to get the whole package
though you can just pay for each thing
like individually which is good
so i just have photoshop illustrator
indesign i use indesign to like lay my
books out but i don't really have after
effects or premiere or anything like
that because i don't really have a lot
of use for that to do like
video editing i don't really like to do
anything super fancy obviously
um so i just have a wondershare from
filmora which
i think i paid like 60 bucks
and you have like license for it like
forever
so
um and it does
pretty much everything i need it to do
so i'm not gonna like pay extra for all
that other crap but yeah and i you have
to pay too for
um
fonts you have to pay for
uh photos you have to pay for all that
kind of [ __ ] really all i have
is
dreams time
which is
photos
and
vector art and that's 30 a month
but it's good to have because they have
like um
you know they have like photos and art
of like everything that you might need
um you know so there's that
uh there's somebody's asking uh
grantham's asked who our favorite porn
stars were
uh i probably have to go by era
because well you can do that if you want
to by era it's not like we have a time
limit [ __ ] changed a lot over the
decades
you know
um
and then you see like well what do you
mean by favorite you know man like
because they had
you know those people were [ __ ]
characters just go back and watch some
of those movies you know like [ __ ] uh
what's the one thought about the porn
stars like it was kind of loosely based
on on real point yeah it was loosely
based on [ __ ]
john holmes um what's in that movie
boogie nights boogie nights yeah yeah
when a lot of that [ __ ] started
it became
like a big money
concept like in california in the 70s
there weren't very many people doing it
so they made a lot of money
and they were they were stars kind of
like of the underground in their own
right they were crazy you know a lot of
[ __ ] crazy
but they were funny you know
so some of them you weren't really
judging by you know their physical
attributes or anything just come more
who they were you know well back then
you kind of had to be okay with being
like outside of the mainstream yeah
because it was a whole sub culture
now it's a lot more mainstreamed but
back then it wasn't like that nowadays
you got girls doing that over their
phone you know [ __ ] and everyone's
like screaming and making my nobody
gives a [ __ ] yeah i could make a porn i
could make [ __ ] a solo porn or [ __ ]
porn legit and put that [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] stream and it wouldn't be
noticed
but in a way i kind of like that
i mean it was kind of cooler back then
because it seemed like it was kind of
sleazy and like underground and stuff
and i and i get that like that was kind
of cooler
but
honestly i think
just for society as a whole i think it's
better now that everybody's just kind of
yeah porn whatever
you know i think people got too upset
about it like back in the day like
everyone got all
oh my god it's pornography yeah now
everybody's just like yeah and
[Laughter]
in the 70s a lot of them seemed kind of
samey
um
me and my friends didn't really notice
any of them until the 80s especially up
in brazil
high school boys all watch porn they all
knew the names of those [ __ ] story we
liked tracy lords we didn't even know
she was underage
because she didn't look underage yeah a
lot of people said that well said they
didn't know i don't know if they
actually did no we didn't know how we no
i'm not talking about you i'm just
talking about like people that made the
movie yeah yeah but no you know the the
public didn't know
she looked like a 21 22 23 she did look
yeah i wouldn't have known that she's
underage but we like tracy lord she was
a [ __ ] superstar she was cute
um and
she kind of had
a personality her and ginger land had
personalities
for the 80s
you know what i mean because you know
[ __ ] was still very uh form very [ __ ]
stagey and studio-ish
there was no such thing as reality
television people really were not being
who they were on screen everything was a
performance but those two you could kind
of tell that they were people the rest
of them were just like mannequins
going through the motions and it was
just yeah i just thought of julianne
moore from uh boogie nights going this
is an enormous [ __ ] yes
exactly that's that's why they were like
that's that's like
right
um
so through the from the 80s those two
stood out stood out and they were two of
the biggest biggest ones
uh 90s [ __ ] there's a lot of them in the
90s because it exploded during the video
era
oh man
jenna fine was probably the best one
from the 90s see i knew tom would have a
lot to say about this jennifer jennifer
was well what made jenna find cool is
that she was on the [ __ ] howard stern
show a lot
and you know she was cool
um
she she had a cool personality and she
had a cool personality on her [ __ ]
videos
she wasn't just always just going
through the motions she talking talking
[ __ ] and [ __ ] you know being normal
on camera
being normal on camera was kind of rare
in the 80s and the 90s because most
people
were staging you know it was kind of fun
it's like oh i'm on tv i'm on tv and
everything's artificial i have to this
is my tv
[Laughter]
which is weird that's another thing that
i'm glad is gone that that kind of like
distinction i know that some people
nowadays complain oh these kids they
spend their entire lives like online
blah blah blah honestly i think that's
good because back in the old days like i
said everybody had like a different
you you seem like you put on a different
persona like when you were on tv or in a
movie or something like that and i don't
think people do that as much anymore
yeah there's like a much more of like a
porous line between the two things yeah
so i would say overall if you're proud
to say the best [ __ ] porn star we're
talking about porn star
that's a thing like saying
a rock star they don't really make those
anymore okay that was something from
pre-internet era i think the best porn
star was jenna fine
because she looked good
she had a personality she would make
public appearances and go on radio shows
uh she'd say funny [ __ ] she was just
like some chick you'd hang out with or
somebody you know in the club it was
just a normal person
and uh her on
her on-screen stuff still
looks it looks pretty modern she wasn't
[ __ ] some of the [ __ ] they do now is
[ __ ] like
skeevy [ __ ] very niche kind of fetish
type porn where it's almost
too much you know i guess it's just well
that's the way you get noticed
i mean porn is so ubiquitous yeah that
you really have to do crazy [ __ ] like to
stand out that's why by today's
standards what she would do what she did
was pretty vanilla uh but what made her
hot is that she made eye contact with
[ __ ] people she was working with they
make eye contact with the camera uh
[ __ ] uh
acted like she was having fun um see
that's kind of a big thing especially
like with female porn stars because
honestly there's not a lot of man ones
because you know
but um
i always kind of liked particularly with
female porn stars do they look like
they're actually enjoying themselves
because you would be surprised a lot of
them particularly back in the old days
not so much nowadays because you can
kind of choose if you want to do it or
not but back then they were just kind of
like they kind of looked like yep let's
uh
get this over with
late 90s early 2000s uh
the one who blew everybody out of the
water really that kind of end she was
probably the last of the what i would
call porn star
was um a girl that was local to the
scene when i was living in
mississippi in louisiana back in those
days
uh belladonna yeah i talked i said i
said
i like her and i like um who's that
other like uh vanessa blue vanessa blue
yeah i like her as well yeah she was
good too because she also
well she also has like a really good
like personality yeah you know what i
mean she had like a lot of personality
kind of having fun dominating people and
[ __ ] yeah i'm all going to get this
oh yeah she's well she was good
she was kind of like she was married to
lexicons lexington steel yeah he was
like always cool also nice and steel
kept winning all these awards and
everything because he was the only
[ __ ] dude in porn that had any
personality the rest of these dudes yeah
it's like a lot of the dudes don't no
i guess most unless it's gay porn like
people aren't usually watching it for
their personalities
but
lexington ski was this big old [ __ ]
black dude man [ __ ] huh all
right and what [ __ ]
his whole [ __ ] thing was that in many
ways he was kind of like the average guy
and he was kind of like average man
mentally women would be these beautiful
[ __ ] women are having sex with him
and he's looking at the cameras going oh
man
[Laughter]
he just can't believe it
his whole thing is he can't [ __ ] take
it he can't okay you guys can't figure
it out and then and [ __ ] there's the
beginning of a reality before the
cameraman asked us how's it going man
how's it going lexi's call oh man oh man
oh man ain't no need you couldn't take
it can't take it and [ __ ] he was married
to vanessa and there are some there's
scenes of those two together like a
dynamite
just you don't believe me google the
[ __ ] yeah mexican steal if it is the
vanessa blue yeah yes those ones are
good yeah and and they're both built and
they're both they're married and they're
[ __ ] doing all kinds of [ __ ] and
she's going oh you think you're a bad
big dick [ __ ]
and he's losing it oh
they're both sexy they broke up though
they broke up oh they're basically
saying they broke up that makes sense um
and then um
i forgot about vanessa and and him
though yeah vanessa too but [ __ ]
probably the last of the [ __ ] i
probably ran into belladonna because she
was hanging out in the french quarter
same time me and my ex-wife were so she
and she was a golf chick so i probably
know who that is but didn't recognize
her
all right because a lot or didn't know
who she was at that time no no because i
really
when i was
going through that first marriage and
everything [ __ ] porn kind of dropped
off for a couple years there i kind of
lost touch with all that [ __ ] i had too
many other things [ __ ] too many
[ __ ] things going at that time she
might have been famous well she would
have been pretty famous at that time and
she was
still in that area
but i think wait a minute
no she wasn't famous at that time
so
chances are i wouldn't i would have
maybe would have met her and she
wouldn't have been famous so i wouldn't
know who it was
because we'd meet everybody yeah down
the crystal and [ __ ]
for all i know she was at uh [ __ ]
pierre's place the [ __ ] convent
yeah but because she wasn't famous and
famous at that time like you wouldn't
know who she was but like i said i like
her because
she's definitely
having fun she's yeah she's into it yeah
and she you can tell that she's into it
and she's having like just a really good
time and she's also like a really savvy
like businesswoman she like really i
don't know how much money she makes out
of the [ __ ] but she's got like her whole
line of yeah back then sex toys and [ __ ]
she knows what she's making now but i
don't know about nowadays but that yeah
people's ability to make money has been
[ __ ] watered down by the internet a
lot
um which that's just it is money making
has been democratized
and a lot of people that own these big
powerful companies don't like it which
is that has to do with a lot of the
[ __ ] problems we're in now but we'll
see how this shit's going
i know the part of this [ __ ] show is
to escape the world's problems
but uh
you know we'll see
um i kind of do kind of miss the the the
the simpler days
but back in those days you had to work
these [ __ ] jobs for these
corporations these [ __ ] businesses
that really were downsizing and always
constantly trying to get rid of you
a la [ __ ] office space if you've ever
seen that movie it was like that
which i'm kind of glad that those jobs
are gone yeah i'm not to get those jobs
well i mean you got to eat and you got
to pay your rent so we wanted you to go
to college to do those [ __ ] stupid
ass jobs that was another thing that
[ __ ] blew my mind but the thing about
it is that even though i'm like
perpetually you know oh my god do i have
enough money to pay my bills this month
but
at least
i get to you know i work really hard and
i work like 12 13 hours a day but at
least it's usually on [ __ ] that i like
yeah like talking to you guys like
reviewing horror movies like reviewing
horror books like at least i usually and
you know graphic design sometimes at
least i usually get to do that
like to make money even though i'm just
you know just kind of getting by i'm not
rich or anything but
honestly when i was growing up i never
could have imagined
that that would have happened i mean
when i was a kid i was like i just
wanted to be a horror writer and i'm
like maybe somebody will discover me
like stephen king and i'll have like
millions of dollars and obviously that
never happened but
at least nowadays i can sort of make a
living at it at [ __ ] that i like doing
because i really really don't like
working for other people i really don't
like being told what to do i really
don't like having to show up at a
particular time every day at a
particular place i just don't like it i
don't and i know a lot of people still
have to do that grantor's asking me this
[ __ ] question
does peter just testosterone make you
make you shoot ropes like [ __ ] peter
north somebody doesn't know what you're
talking about
some of you youngsters may not know what
he's talking about peter north of this
[ __ ] buffed out [ __ ] porn star
he was known for these [ __ ] massive
[ __ ] loads
but [ __ ] go back and go look at that
[ __ ] [ __ ] grafters that's just clear
as water because [ __ ] he's shut down
like crazy
um
he's
okay
there's been much said about that okay
they're like [ __ ] why is that so
[ __ ] clear they had people in the
industry going was he just pissing on
him or whatever
what the hell is going on that's just
water does he have a bladder in there
yeah
it was quite voluminous there's a lot of
it but it was [ __ ] clear you said
voluminous yeah volume there was a lot
of it that's one of my i know that's one
of my favorite vocabulary words all
right so some people are saying he must
be just peeing on him that's fake that's
not this is what i think was going on
chris
he's definitely [ __ ] on steroids
when you're on gear
if you're young well just period if
you're on gear
your android system sees that
those uh steroids which are just a
modified testosterone that's all it is
it sees that in your bloodstream and it
shuts down your
nuts all right
your nuts are like why do i why do i
have to make any testosterone [ __ ] we
got plenty of it so i'm going to take
vacation i'm just going to relax i'm
going to relax i'm going to put my
little nut down
i just pictured a pair of testicles with
little feet
yeah so after a [ __ ] couple months
you know what i mean you just it ends up
being kind
it ends up becoming literally male
contraception
your nuts shut down
they go
dormant and they stop making spermatozoa
so you become chemically cast chemically
sterilized
from the hormonal imbalance
you're now sterile you can't have
children
your nuts aren't making any [ __ ]
testosterone and they aren't making any
sperm either
but your prostate gland is still making
um
seminal fluids okay so that's what
you're seeing
i believe
um although
some guys when they're older when
they're totally shut down there isn't
even any fluids at all
okay but with a young guy it might be
because peter north was young at that
time might be that you still might make
semen which is just a clear fluid like a
lubricant
um
so that it's either that's probably what
you're seeing there
um
so no sperm but semen
sounds technical it sounds like medical
issues that's gross
but that's
that's that that that's what i believe
it's not gross those that's the proper
note
yeah i know it sounds great but most
guys when they get shut down
not only does not only does the [ __ ]
um
sperm stop being produced the semen
styles being produced too so
when you reach uh when you reach orgasm
nothing at all comes out it's called
shooting blanks you just cheat blanks
nothing comes out
which that's not a problem you know um
it's just that's why there is no male
birth control pill
because some dudes they don't want to i
guess they think that's embarrassing i
don't know men or men are inventing this
[ __ ] and then maybe they can't market
that to men
but almost every bodybuilder is like
that
nothing will come out
yeah not unless they're taking something
called hcg which i take that
it's a pituitary gland stimulant which
keeps that which is constantly
almost literally
kicking the pituitary gland into [ __ ]
action to cause all your glands to
continue production
so um i still got it
uh it's not as much as it was before
um
but you know i'm 53 you know the [ __ ]
content of all of all that [ __ ] kind of
starts declining anyway over over time
when you're [ __ ] in your teens
early 20s
sometimes you can produce just [ __ ]
ignoring inordinate amounts of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know you scare a woman away
you [ __ ]
take that [ __ ] take that here like
she's like i don't want to get pregnant
i'm out of here
yeah she's like i'm the one that's got
to deal with this [ __ ] is too
potent and [ __ ]
and the way the abortion laws are going
to think that's just come out women
think this is cool it's just
younger women think that's just real
cool but uh do they
uh yeah according to them
i never heard that yeah
i've seen [ __ ] maybe they don't try
to get maybe they maybe they just told
you that like to make oh look at that
honey it was just like so and they're
just like it's aj
okay whatever
well you know we say a lot of stuff to
like massage male ego is that what it is
yeah you really shouldn't have been with
a man you should have been with a woman
probably
that's how [ __ ] should have been down
with you probably you think i think so
yeah i should honestly we need to get
you another girlfriend honestly i i'm
kind of like i like being on my own i
like my own selves is that what it is
you like yourself now yeah okay let me
go to the restroom
i need to go too actually but god i'm so
behind with the [ __ ] comments
um yeah lala oh that's right i think you
reminded me lyrica dude said i know this
is a long time ago i'm like really
behind uh lala ward used to be married
to richard dawkins that's right now
they're not together anymore right
are they did she die
i don't know but i remember because i
used to read a lot of like richard
dawkins stuff and i remember like them
saying oh my god she used to be married
to like one of the doctor who's and
that's like really weird
uh john smith said speaking of terms of
terror my copy of the of uh cunning folk
arrived today i hope you like it i
really liked that um if you're into folk
horror
um and you didn't see my review of
cunning folk by adam
adam neville who also wrote no one gets
out alive
um it's actually it's really really good
it's like it's folk horror and also like
neighbors from hell
kind of uh situation yeah i was like
really into it
um mego says if it's any con consolation
all fire starter star movies will suck
the original did i don't think the
original sucked it could have been
better
but i don't know i have like a lot of
nostalgia for it i guess rebecca says
anyone seen bone tomahawk on netflix i
love bone tomahawk we reviewed that like
not too long ago
um
literally felt like puking yeah uh the
thing about bone tomahawk is that
a lot of it is just it's like a western
but then like at the end it just goes
like full-on
gore you know what i mean so
yeah but it's good it's it's a great
great movie i love that [ __ ] movie we
have it uh we own it and we like
reviewed it i've seen it like several
times
i've seen it several times
yeah eat and i i honestly still have
kind of like a hard time watching that
[ __ ] and i've watched
more [ __ ] up [ __ ] than that but i
don't know why
it bothers me a lot in that film just
because i guess it was so [ __ ]
realistic and because it was so
it wasn't like the movie was just like a
wall-to-wall gore-fest it was just
mostly like a western with some horror
elements and then all of a sudden hey
we're
slicing a dude in half
and and now we're doing that so you know
and it's very very realistic so yeah
it's like pretty [ __ ] up
and more more porn talk yeah what are we
doing marilyn chambers is the only day
yeah interestingly when i was i was just
thinking about maryland chambers last
night because
the
history of horror show they were talking
about one of the episodes was called
infections and they talked about rabid
the david cronenberg movie
and so they were talking about maryland
chambers and honestly i think marilyn
chambers did a [ __ ] great job in that
movie for being like a porn star and
that was like her first like real movie
quote-unquote you want to say that like
mainstream movie and i thought she was
[ __ ] great in that
i still haven't seen the rabid remake is
it any good has anybody seen it i kind
of want to see it but i've heard like
mixed reviews i'm excited about the new
david cronenberg movie that's coming out
which is called crimes of the future the
trailer looks
amazing
um
but i don't know when it's coming out
like in wide release i guess next month
they're showing it at can
uh the cam film festival but
i don't know when we're gonna see it i
want to [ __ ] see it
because he hasn't made a new movie since
what was the last one he made it was
like a long time ago i know his son
brandon has made a couple
um you know he made possessor and he
made that other one what was that one
called antiviral or whatever that one
was called and his uh brandon cronenberg
like has made some amazing ones too but
i don't even remember one like the last
time
i know he did eastern promises he did
history of violence i know he's done one
since then has he
yeah i can't even remember i can't just
misses it was your review that made him
buy it i don't know what he's talking
about
cunning folk okay it's a book all right
yeah i mean i hope you like it because i
i know this is like gonna sound weird
but
i'm always kind of like
i l you know i don't know i like
particular books and it's like i review
them and i always kind of like recommend
them if you like xyz
but i always kind of feel like i don't
want somebody to come at me if they like
read the book and they're like you told
me that it was good and that's not good
and barbara you know what i mean so i i
always kind of like have weird like
anxiety about that but i really liked
cunning folk like i said if you if you
really like folk horror and you really
like neighbors from hell type stories
then that one was really good
so
and adam neville's other [ __ ] um
[Music]
no one gets out alive was also really
good i heard they made that into a movie
or a series but i haven't seen it i
think it's on netflix i'll have to watch
that like one of these days because that
was also a really good book although i
heard that one of his other books and i
can't remember what it was called now
but i heard that other one was like not
very good but i don't know so what day
is momenta opening
they're doing it on the sunday before
memorial day so it's the sunday at the
end of this month okay so we got about
three weeks two weeks two weeks i think
two weeks two weeks you wanna go to that
what day is that on
sunday it's a sunday night it's a sunday
before cause that's an easy drive
yeah
okay yeah momento mori our night at uh
which was at eyebar barbarella obviously
barbarella is not downtown orlando
anymore they moved
out to [ __ ] john young parkway do you
want to go out to tomorrow night
to who mannequins mannequins yeah we
could okay
if we're not gonna go go to the movie
then we'll go out just go to mannequins
all right
yeah that should be fun i'd rather dance
tonight at mannequins they're actually
doing
uh it's friday the 13th so they're doing
a superstition
cosplay you're supposed to dress up like
your favorite superstition i don't know
what they're doing tomorrow night though
i ain't playing that game i never
dreamed i'd never dress up for anything
i know time's not fun no
[Laughter]
you're spending money i'm no fun
[Laughter]
strong 78 says jenna jameson yeah she
was kind of like a popular pick i
honestly i read her
autobiography talk about porn star still
yeah okay i read her autobiography
a while back
and she seemed i don't you know i'm sure
she wrote it with somebody but that book
was like fascinating
she was kind of she she
was generic for the time a lot of them
were a lot of them were yeah
john smith says porno horror crossover
the professor from cannibal holocaust is
in debbie does dallas oh i didn't even
know that
well
uh
yeah they were talking about rebecca was
talking about uh bone tomahawk she just
saw it yeah you know my friend did the
sound for that he's on the show all the
time in the comments section yeah yeah
uh and then tammy says yeah i only
watched it after tom and jenny reviewed
it and haven't got the nerve up to
re-watch it i really enjoyed the rest of
the movie though yeah most of the movie
you'll be fine like most of the movie is
good but yeah when it gets to that one
scene
you'll know what i'm talking about um
that's pretty [ __ ] up it's it's pretty
hard to watch he did the um sound for we
went to military school together
getting all kinds of messages
yeah i was like i got way behind yeah i
got way behind oh that [ __ ] keith
sending me [ __ ] about flacca
yeah blitz phantom said i was thinking
history of violence is his last movie
but i could be wrong see i that's what i
thought too i thought history of
violence was last one and that was a
long time ago because i remember seeing
that in the [ __ ] theater and that was
ages ago yeah but i don't know if david
croninberg's made one sense then but
like i said brandon cronenberg's made a
couple his first one i think was called
antiviral and i reviewed that and
possessor and we reviewed that
um and those are both actually excellent
but
the new david cronenberg looks
pretty sweet
i mean it looks it's very cronenbergy so
if you are waiting for like a return to
form because i know when he did like
history of violence and eastern promises
he went like more in a
crime thriller direction which was fine
with me because those were both really
good movies but i think people were kind
of like booked when are you gonna get
back to like the body horror and like
all that [ __ ] up [ __ ] used to
and this looks like he's gonna do that
so
i mean big time so
i'm into it i'm into it and let's
rando question says grant yeah we need
to get the um did you ever figure out
how to get the software to go so we
could have him on
i want to have brian on
i didn't know i was supposed to be doing
that yeah yeah
we were on the show when i said that
figure out how we can have a [ __ ]
yeah but you say a lot of things on the
show and i don't know and i don't yeah i
don't remember because a lot of things
you say and you don't like all right
we're going to hook that [ __ ] up like we
did for for agp and some of the other
guests we had years back when we had
guests i want i want [ __ ] a hackett
to [ __ ] brian
i want brian hackett to come on as a
guest
we went to military academy together
southern california military military
academy out
in california and we grew up in the
military academy it was a [ __ ] great
school [ __ ] we have all good memories
of it
and um
he worked on bone tomahawk worked on vfw
uh works he's working he worked on a new
gina carano flick that's coming out
worked on that last one
shut in shut in
[ __ ] he he knows crustal he worked
with crystal on [ __ ] mini shows he
was on [ __ ] um
i think
i think he said he worked on [ __ ]
escape escape from la
and uh he's just been he he did sound
for a lot of [ __ ] movies and uh
he has a lot of good information you
know i'm never going to get the dude to
[ __ ] say anything to get himself in
trouble but we talk we talk offline all
the time
about certain things and
i haven't seen the new [ __ ] batman
i said dude i want to see the batman
he's like oh [ __ ] the batman that's
going to suck and it seems like the
[ __ ] audience is mostly like this i
think he called the batman wrong
but um
the movies he worked on i [ __ ] liked
every one of them he worked on
he'd be a good guest
i haven't talked to him since i was a
kid because he's not face to face you
know
but we got to get the uh gotta get this
program set up to do that
i'll ask him i'll contact him when the
show's over
find out exactly what is he what he's on
if he's on a [ __ ] pc or if he's on a
[ __ ] cell phone or whatever
and see what it is well it's not so much
that it's like what platform does he use
his views right sky april does he use
[ __ ] other [ __ ] i'm gonna find out
from him what he uses i kind of feel
like a lot of people don't even use
skype anymore because or zoom or
whatever 13 o'clock we do have some
hollywood inside action okay
[ __ ] um
some of my ex-girlfriends are [ __ ]
hollywood they're famous in hollywood
got friends that are famous in there
the movie scene is a scene that will
[ __ ] be around for a long time
hollywood as you know it i think is kind
of a dying thing it's now being spread
out
um across the united states and the
world
um
movie making will always be movie making
but the old
studio model
come on man
come on man that sounds like joe biden
there for a minute it's just um they
don't need to make as many of them as
they used to because television
cable and then the internet and
everything ever you know what i mean
it's second
how are you going to compete against
that
the studio model was made in the [ __ ]
started it out of the 20s and the 30s
when there was no television
so you had to [ __ ] be a factory a
movie factory
i think that's dead
why waste all your time making all those
damn mediocre movies because [ __ ]
face it most of them are mediocre why
not [ __ ]
concentrate your efforts on making five
really good movies a year per studio
that's all you need
then you'd make billions probably just
off those millions oh just off those
movies
see what i'm saying yeah yeah
because there's so many movies that are
made all the time that nobody ever sees
them and they're quickly
forgotten yeah you know
mango says the remake of rabid is very
good but not really like the original i
watched it and loved it and i love the
original see i'm i don't know i've been
like interested in watching it but i've
heard it was good so
um bring it back to friday 13th totally
weird saying cronenberg and jason x yeah
that's right he wasn't that wasn't he
yeah he shows up in
movies from time to time like isn't
david kernenberg okay like as an actor
yeah
uh let's see wait granthar's asked a
couple questions what is the worst
horror movie of all time
ooh oh it's hard to say that
i mean
hmm
i keep thinking i'm i'm thinking of like
the ones that were on [ __ ] case cinema
there was one that he covered on there
that i've actually seen that's called
things
it might be canadian i'm not entirely
sure but it looked like some
people just made it like around their
house
and uh that's pretty dire yeah although
like going back to the old like actually
more like a real movie
um
the blood waters of dr z yeah that was
made in florida and mr ada says that
hollywood is mostly contracted around
tent pole movies this yes that's what
they have to do
it should be mostly temple movies
all those little movies that they used
to use to as a substitute for television
that's all [ __ ]
why are they even bothering
you need to have a lot of little studios
like [ __ ] with a24 israel a24 82
what's the name of the a24 a24 yeah
they're they're good they come up with
little artsy films and you you can play
those at amc
just on little contracts but really if
you're gonna play that [ __ ] on the
[ __ ] big screen the quality has got
to be good or nobody's coming
so it's got to go to [ __ ] these 10
pool movies or really good independent
flicks none of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
well honestly studios like blumhouse
have a good stuff good well they have a
good market going because they're like
look we're gonna to make horror movies
for the horror market and they're all
going to cost under 10 million dollars
right and they almost always make their
money yeah that's what you do they
almost always make you have that [ __ ]
hooked up with good with good theaters
like [ __ ] amazing like i said go
niche that's what you got to do unless
you can make a movie like an avengers
movie that everyone's going to go see
that makes billions of dollars
then go right yeah find a niche that has
like enough people to support it and
just like make a smaller movie and there
are some movies that i would think that
oh man nobody'll see that but they did
see it like we saw that stupid-ass
rom-com
with that fat girl that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
good
it was yeah that was good
but it was also promoted right i knew
that was going to be a good movie when i
saw the trailers
you know
yeah what was the name of that movie i
can't remember now
it wasn't funny though it was also
[ __ ] it was right it was rebel
wallace yeah yeah yeah she was riffing
on
yeah it was like a parody but it was
also like a rom-com in its own
right but it was a parody of them right
and like a really funny parody it ended
up just being a comedy yeah and uh yeah
i liked it it was worth seeing
would i have paid 10 bucks to see it no
but would i see that on [ __ ] on
[ __ ] stubs amc stubs [ __ ] thing
where you get see get to see three
movies a week yeah hell yeah
enjoyed it
yeah that's why i didn't get too mad
about like because we saw a lot of
[ __ ] stinkers on that on stuff
because remember back in the old days we
used to record the reviews like live in
the theater like after the movies were
over we just used more movies
and we kept seeing so we saw like three
movies every single week whether there
was [ __ ] playing we wanted to know or
not
and
i mean some of the stuff actually turned
out being better than i thought and it
was something that i wouldn't have seen
otherwise
but some of the stuff was like [ __ ]
painful yeah so it was just bad like
that holmes and watson movie oh
god that was painful
there was some of the [ __ ] that was
surprisingly good remember the one that
was more like a
more like a [ __ ]
it was
it was about gay therapy and the
religious people i was just thinking
about that one
that was good
it was what the [ __ ] was the name of
that i think nicole kidman was in that
was she not wasting
that i don't know
she was just about a boy
no that was that that was it was a
little it was a little independent film
yeah that was actually really good i
think it was based on a book actually
yeah it was a little independent film
what the [ __ ] about a gay kid
from a religious family keeps getting
got sent to [ __ ] to one of those
way the gay awakening is funny as [ __ ] i
mean and also kind of horrifying yeah
and it was based on something that
really happened yeah i think it was
based on someone's memoir yeah it's
based on something that really happened
what the [ __ ] was that movie called and
that was a good movie it was that it had
boy in the title yeah and it was funny
is that it came and went like it never
existed well it was a good one i'm used
to i mean look i grew up in central
florida my whole life and i'm
i like weird movies i like indie movies
and [ __ ] like that i've just become
resigned to the fact that hardly
anything that i want to see
plays here it just doesn't um
it's better now than it used to be
because we have like bigger theaters and
like at least they'll kind of give a sop
to hey here you can have this indie
movie for like a couple of days like in
this dinky little theater and then it'll
go away so at least you do get to see it
but
back in the day
most of the movies i wanted to see did
not play here so i had to wait till they
had till they came out in like [ __ ]
dvd so i didn't get to see a lot of the
[ __ ] that i wanted to see on like the
big screen and then there was a [ __ ]
there was a real [ __ ] stinker
a kenny reeves stinker
that bombed for him but i still liked it
it was the one about the genetic
engineering that's right and his family
i didn't mind that movie yeah yeah it
was that right it bombed though [ __ ]
nobody saw it nobody saw it
well it was a little it was a river it
was derivative yeah yeah it was kind of
like i was going back in time to the 90s
and watching and that's all it was it
wasn't bad no i liked it i liked it
actually i liked it it was just yeah i
seen it yeah it was kind of comforting
though it was like yeah i've seen these
before i know what they're doing
you know didn't we see one that was like
a tear like a dog movie like a terrible
weird christian yeah yeah yeah with the
dog that talked
the dog and the voice wow that was that
one sucked all the time
i hate those kind of movies yeah dog
movie that we saw a lot of painful
movies we saw burn the stage remember
that with the korean boy band i was yeah
they
and i'm trying to watch this [ __ ] to
review it for the show and i'm like
looking around and it's all these little
fan girls [ __ ] dressed up in [ __ ]
yeah
because like it was the end of the week
i said we need a third movie and i was
like this is all that's playing yeah so
we i was like i really don't want to see
this but we went to see it and it's like
it the the theater was kind of like it
wasn't full but it was like pretty full
and it was all like teenage girls and
like their moms yeah and so me and him
are sitting there i said i kind of feel
like a creeper right now like
like we're the only like middle-aged
people that don't have like teenage
girls with us that it was like
is somebody gonna call the police yeah
that was [ __ ] funny and then like uh
okay
well we were on a marathon to see as
many movies as we could
some days we'd see two or three like in
one day like we'd go see a movie then
we'd go eat lunch and then we'd go watch
another one like we had everything we
had it all scheduled and look that
sounds like that's easy that's work you
get sick of that real quick
well because most of the movies i mean
to be fair
really
um
there would be a movie i really wanted
to see maybe like once a month or once
every two months like something horror
or something sci-fi or something like
weird or like some weird indie thing
yeah most of the other stuff i was just
kind of like well i guess we gotta see
this yeah it's like oh
and i was just like i didn't really want
to i didn't honestly most of the ones i
didn't mind i didn't mind like the
animated ones yeah they were good those
are usually fun pixar animated things
pixar or even like dreamworks or whoever
the hell sometimes those were usually
entertaining sometimes i'm watching
those things and i'm going you know what
i [ __ ] wish i would have smoked
[ __ ] a whole bunch of weed before i
watched this this movie would be awesome
see that's what would be even better if
i was high
[Laughter]
the grinch movie and [ __ ] so that have
been even better honestly i kind of
liked that grinch yeah and it was a good
movie then there was some of them that
were [ __ ] awesome but then i forgot
all about them like [ __ ] bright burn
[ __ ] i really like that one yeah what
happened to that remember that one we
saw too that was called freaks
do you remember that one was that the
one about the little girl and the dad
that were like trapped in the house like
she had like powers or something kinda
do you remember that one uh vaguely yeah
that was good too i remember like really
liking that one so yeah there were like
a lot of ones that kind of came and went
where i was like well that was pretty
good i mean i like it because i mean we
still pay for it it's just the theater
is like so much farther away now and
because we expanded out the matinee show
to just like cover whatever
streaming or old movies new movies
whatever i kind of feel like when we
first started matinee i was kind of like
oh well
you know we're gonna go see new movies
and we're gonna like review them like on
the fly like right after we see them but
then like after a while that just became
unsustainable and i was like look
there's so many other movies that we
need to cover that we are not covering
on our retrospective show which is just
once a week and it's like there's a
whole bunch of movies that i want to
talk about and we just won't get around
to so i just wanted to expand it out and
especially like after covid came and
like the theaters were closed and stuff
so i was like well we gotta
find movies somewhere so we just
expanded it out and like like we said it
kind of got really tiring
going to the theater i like going to
theater i like seeing movies in the
theater but
it got kind of to be a slog after a
while because it's like oh it's like
well we haven't seen this one and it's
just like some lame ass like [ __ ]
rom-com or some weird christian movie or
something just like i really don't want
to see that
but it's like i felt like we had to
because that was like what we committed
to do
and so we saw like a bunch of [ __ ] that
i probably wouldn't have wasted my time
on otherwise
but as i said on the good side of that i
did end up seeing a lot of movies that
were way better than i expected that i
probably wouldn't have watched otherwise
because it's not like a genre that i
would normally watch
granthars also asks this is an
interesting question yes
how many ex-lovers do you keep in touch
with
um
not really anything i don't think so
no not really any i don't think
well not really maybe you want like
every now and then but it might be
really a lot of the ex-girlfriends that
i've had in this area they're still
running around they're still friends of
mine so now that you keep in touch with
them you just see them all the time
like a later yeah you know
yeah she's still yeah like we still talk
yeah we still talk to her because she's
like still around so we hooked her up
with her husband yeah
yeah she's married now we just saw them
a few weeks ago you got to remember
grabbed us you're not dealing with
conventional people we don't care about
that [ __ ] man
although now
now that i'm thinking about sleep with
everybody with each other all the time
as you know we
now that i'm thinking about it i can't
really yeah
think of anybody that i it's not an
issue for us
it's a small community we all know each
other
there isn't a lot of jealousy because
nobody's going anywhere
[Laughter]
you're not going anywhere
okay
it's a sign of weaknesses you're jealous
lars alright said have you thought about
doing a show about the paul is dead
theory
did we talk about that from from from
the beatles yeah didn't we do a show
okay a while back we did a show about
like rock star
or you know rock music legends
did we talk about that on there or no i
can't remember
what did we talk about on there here's
the thing about the paula's dead thing
i got a piece that might that might
actually kind of fold in with back
backwards masking
is that yeah because that's part of that
you're getting some ass on you girl
what what yeah i'm just now getting some
[ __ ] i never had a dad you see listen
she's walking around looking you know
what you doing pokey
um
yeah the whole paul is dead thing you
know a lot of that has to do with the
song revolution not in revolution nine
and um then you know him walking across
[ __ ] abbey road with his [ __ ]
barefoot in his suit and the whole paul
is dead thing i don't know if that
could fill an entire show
that subject isn't that big
but that particular subject might fit
well on a backward masking show
and uh
because the backward masking show i
think you know there's a lot of that
but backward masking was the troll it
was a troll you know
that would astound us back in the age
vinyl though
we'd put the [ __ ] needle on the
phonograph turn that [ __ ] around
backwards
yeah all kind of but they were doing it
on purpose too you know iron maiden was
recording things backwards and [ __ ]
putting that in the songs and
they knew you were looking for it
but then i remember we used to put the
[ __ ]
yo she
remember we used to [ __ ] put that
put the put the photograph needle
on [ __ ]
that led zeppelin song [ __ ] stairway
to heaven and go back and go back
go back and it would sound like it it
would sound like it was sand stuff but
it wasn't
yeah they had whole radio shows about
that christians would come on there
and try to scare the [ __ ] out of people
i really wouldn't call them christians
they were just people making money off
of christians scaring the hell out of
them
oh my god everybody's worshiping the
satan listen
the music industry the rock music
industry is [ __ ] channeling demons
and
sure that'll happen which them then the
heavy metal scene dove right into that
oh we gotta have some backer baskets on
our album yeah yeah
that's a good way to get some free ass
hell yeah
bands like venom and slayer and [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] appeared with [ __ ]
satanic black metal and just yeah
they walked right into that [ __ ] lean
into it and what was funny is you know i
would listen to venom i was new back in
the [ __ ] the 80s
welcome to hell black metal album
[ __ ] uh in the [ __ ] in league with
satan [ __ ] they had all kinds of
[ __ ] good albums you know at war with
satan it's a good album
and uh go back and listen to the [ __ ]
it was like listening to a horror movie
you know
the problem with those satanic metal
bands is that
once you start talking about satan
and satanism
you're kind of trapped into that
it's got to stay like that you can't
jump out of that and start talking about
politics you can't jump out of that and
[ __ ] do a love song it's got to be
that
and that's why i love satan all the time
yeah all satan all the time 24 7
[ __ ] 30 days and it probably gets
boring it's like we have to write here's
our 40 bajillion 40 billionth jaw
and we've talked about satan and we're
going to talk about werewolves and we
talk about canis bathory we've talked
about the angels are we
and possession and the [ __ ] what the
priest says when you're possessed and
[ __ ] you know just because
you're going through it and they go oh
yeah they they
i guess they saw the exorcist also you
know
that's what they're that's their source
material
your brother sucks
man
[Laughter]
even though there's a [ __ ]
out of them all
i'm old school out of them all
[ __ ] venom was the best black metal
band it was like real hard rock
like a dumbed down version of motorhead
with just [ __ ] okay we're getting
super chats finally y'all mangoes say
five pounds venom
venom was the best one
because it was what it was and they were
kind of like the originators of it
um cradle of filth came out and they
kind of had it was a little more
elevated a little more high-tech
but it just didn't have the place and
time wasn't the same at least not for me
cradle of filth always seemed like a
[ __ ] copy
you know like it was not an original the
original was venom
you know
i mean that's the thing it's kind of
like
i don't know i don't mean to cast
aspersions on
people that do black metal or death
metal or whatever but it is
a bit of a narrow genre yeah in that way
um
yeah so once you kind of get there's
only like uh
a limited amount of
uh approved topics you're allowed like
right talked about what are you gonna do
i guess you're gonna have a [ __ ] saw
you're gonna have an album with a
[ __ ] pentagram the devil's face on it
and you're gonna have [ __ ] all these
songs about what's happening in hell and
what happened in heaven in the past and
the war between the angels and the
demons and [ __ ] what happens when the
[ __ ] child gets possessed and the
sacrifice of the virgin and this and
that and then all of a sudden you're
gonna [ __ ] make a love song it's not
gonna fit and then all of a sudden
you're gonna complain about republicans
or democrats it's not gonna fit you're
not gonna pop none of the earthly topics
fit in that now
yeah to to go outside that you've now
broken character
because it is an act yes this is theater
all right and that's the thing that
a lot of parents
of the older generations of the boomer
generations you know i mean [ __ ] like
our parents you know they didn't
understand that this is theater
yeah this isn't reality this is theater
it's like putting in a [ __ ] horror
movie or this and you know or
they didn't really get they didn't get
that they didn't get that either right
yeah
they didn't understand fiction i mean my
parents were cool but i kind of feel
like a lot of people might or not even
my parents my grandparents age
they didn't really get why people
were into horror movies and they thought
that
people that were into horror movies
especially like back in the 80s when it
was like all slashers though you must be
like a [ __ ] degenerate or something
like that to be like watching that i'm
like that's not why people watch it yeah
it's somebody telling you a story
from something that is not normal it's
not the normal
realm of [ __ ] everyday mundane life
this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is this is ed kemper
telling you a story or this is like you
know
so
i don't know what it was our generation
instantly knew
that things like black metal were not
real
that they are putting on a show and it
is definitely a kabuki theater because
everything's over the [ __ ] top
you know what i mean yeah they're not
even using their own names like the the
names of the [ __ ] band members are
kronos
abaddon
and mantis
so they don't they're not even using
their own names this is theater
they're playing roles yeah and they got
the [ __ ] from kiss
really that's that's the root cause is
kiss
what you really think that's the way
those [ __ ] dressed you think
yeah when they're going down to like the
grocery store to get a kitty litter or
asparagus
right right yeah i'm gonna go in full
makeup [ __ ] that [ __ ] gene simmons goes
down with his [ __ ] bat wings and his
platform
and buy some kitty litter yeah this is
[ __ ]
this is [ __ ] theater
and it's it's japanese style kabuki
theater you know they have the white
makeup and the eye makeup and [ __ ]
over the over-the-top haircuts and [ __ ]
so
well the thing about it is that from the
late 60s early 70s and you had like the
onset of like glam and things like that
where
people were it would you know it was you
were uh you had a persona everybody that
wasn't really you you're right you were
it was just a character yeah
strong 70s and 80s everybody got that
70s and 80s were innovating all that you
know and it wasn't just white people
that was also happening with all the
black bands yeah you know [ __ ] they
were doing the exact same thing
this is theater
you know just watch soul train and
[ __ ] you'll see they'll have bands on
there they'll do [ __ ] the old soul
train that shit's probably on you on
youtube you definitely see that that is
not life that there's just watch a rick
james video rick james is a crazy
[ __ ] though man [ __ ] okay he was
but he is also a character and he's a
character in his videos he's a character
in his [ __ ] on his albums
um
to a certain extent so is prince
princess being a character
um was he kind of like that though in
real life according to dave chappelle
and everybody else yeah he was kind of
like that but
it was it was the 80s well it's like an
idealized
projection the same thing happens in the
goth scene sure you have people there
doing their thing and you know they're
they're not really like that but that's
the way they are when they're in the
club and that's what's happening
it's
although i kind of feel i'm glad that
like the heyday because i feel like the
heyday of that was the 90s yeah when
everybody
you know was introducing themselves as
like
you know i am dark willow and i'm just
you know and everybody had like a name
yeah they were like the fake fangs and
stuff and i was like oh god can you not
i mean but you know what i mean yeah so
there was that it was it was a little
much yeah uh he went over the top yeah i
kind of feel like that really wasn't
going on that much in the 80s but in the
90s like after goth got mainstreamed a
little bit then suddenly you got all of
these kids and like i said i'm not
[ __ ] on them they were probably like
teenagers and stuff but yeah they were
very like i am so like i'm so angsty and
i'm just so this isn't that and it was
just like they were just like really for
old [ __ ] like me it was like really
tiresome so
there was that but i don't know i i'm
all about like people
projecting
uh
you know the persona that they want to
project but
i don't know it's hard for me to say
because i'm just kind of like i'm not
good at that i'm not like projecting
something other than what i'm really
like i don't know how to be other than
i'm so somebody said like earlier on
that on one show i should dress like a
normie and i thought to myself i didn't
i didn't say it because it's got like
[ __ ] uh lost when i was like uh
scrolling upward but
i don't um actually know how to do that
i don't know how to do that if i tried
to do that because i've tried to do that
before like i try to dress like a normal
person like sometimes if i had to go to
like a job interview or something like
that and
i still looked like a weirdo and i
couldn't figure out why that was because
i'm just like so used to looking like a
weirdo that
i can't like look like a normal person i
don't know what the normal person looks
like
it's just like i don't know it's a very
weird thing
um
slash friend said i know that many
people now have a distaste for remakes
but the film they should remake is
killer clowns from outer space
i don't know i don't know if that's a
one that they should because that has a
very specific
look to it and honestly the killer
clowns look i
love love
the production design of that movie i
love the costumes i love the design of
the spaceship i just love everything
about the look of that movie and i don't
know i just kind of feel like they would
cgi the [ __ ] out of it and i'm not i'm
not about it not about it
not about it um
[Music]
holy parish of doom who i think you told
me last time that your name was peter so
that's what i'm going to call you i'm
the same long-haired bearded guy i was
when i was a teenager in the 80s yeah
honestly
i haven't honestly changed all that much
um you know i was still like a weird
punk death rock chick in the 80s
late 80s and i still kind of look like
that nowadays and i've been like that so
long that i don't really know how to do
anything else if somebody told me hey
you have to look normal for some
function or something i wouldn't have
any idea what to do about it
bundy data said the heat in florida will
make you dress down it does it's kind of
like a bummer
doing the goth thing in florida it can
be done because there's variations but
i'm not gonna lie i do have like a bunch
of really really cool
like goth jackets and like outfits and
stuff like that that i can't really wear
like more than once a year because it's
so [ __ ] hot down here
yeah
well
nothing oh it sounds like you lost your
connection that's that that's like you
no i was just i lost the connection
sound you know we don't lose them
anymore
well he's better we better not because
now not only do we have
not only do we have the cable but now we
have another modem right there i know
in addition to the one that's downstairs
we got a lot of people online for this
show did we really 32 online for this
show that might that might be a record
that's almost a record actually is it
is it i have no idea
i don't know i can't i'm not on youtube
i'm going through obs so i can't see
like how many people
all i can see is us and the chat i can't
see like all the youtube
[ __ ]
mrs evans says that we are preaching to
the choir
they talk about chronos and d.o yeah
the thing is though is that ronnie james
was not a character
he was being himself
um
but uh he was great he was great with
[ __ ] i think he started off in a
rainbow didn't he um
he started yeah yeah yeah i think so
then he went uh [ __ ] uh dio
he might have he was in black sabbath
for he was in black sabbath and then he
went then he went solo
and um
ronnie was
the great thing about ronnie is that
ronnie [ __ ] wrote awesome [ __ ]
lyrics
and uh
he was just a [ __ ] very
fantastical little guy and i'm saying
little he was little he was only a 5'4
little skinny guy little i think he was
italian italian american
with a [ __ ] fantastic voice
if you were to hear him
on headphones back in the day you would
think this is a eight foot tall
[ __ ] just this god
you know
you know going on and on about [ __ ]
you know
uh in the misty morning you don't like
kind of shaking on it yeah and it was
like very much kind of like when he
started
it's kind of like a couple notches above
led zeppelin
all right
a little bit darker and a little bit
more intense
uh he was he's great and poor ronnie got
killed by cancer just 80 bucks
um but everybody who knew ron who knew
ronnie
came out uh when he died and all that
stuff came out online to talk about what
an awesome guy he was everybody loved
him
everybody loved him he sound kind of
intimidating certain times with dio
you know [ __ ]
almost like some kind of a i don't want
to say satanic it did kind of have that
flavor at first but then when you really
paid attention to his lyrics it was more
mystical he was into mystical stuff
uh in the end positive positive
positivity and a lot of strength
um
great vocalist great vocalist uh
and a poor guy got whittled down to
nothing and [ __ ] we've had friends
die of cancer it's just [ __ ] sad
cancer is a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it really
is
it's killed two of our friends this year
this year very very young both of them
beautiful young women young yeah
they're in their 30s in their 30s yeah
kaylee got killed and amber and amber
yeah and and they were both hotties
just out of nowhere got him
yeah
it's [ __ ] yeah it's pitiless that's
what sucks kaley was cute but amber
would have been like a [ __ ] poster
model for goth clubs that's that you
know cute
you don't believe me i'll show you
yeah
i think well you've shot a picture of
her before right yeah yeah but we're
showing you this no i was just saying i
thought we i thought yeah a long time
ago because she yeah she died yeah
i mean we know and she looked good we
knew we knew it was coming we knew it
was coming and she looked good her whole
life
because we have another friend yeah who
has breast cancer yeah and she's older
she's our age
and they were
doing chemo together with her and amber
amber had i think it was was it stomach
cancer yeah amber bellco that's what my
uh grandma died of
that was that was amber and she died
and she looked like that when she died
last time we saw a couple weeks later
then she just died
let's see yeah we saw her not too long
ago yeah
yeah poor amber
so it doesn't
it doesn't just strike down
old people
you know
well yeah trying to see a picture of
amber just real dressed up just decked
out
to get an idea who it was
all her stuff's online is so sad still
yeah i mean it wasn't she didn't do it
that long ago
like i said we knew it was common but
then like we just heard about it like
not too long ago when i was like ah
that's a bummer
we just saw a few months
we saw a few months ago with memento
and then she
didn't she had that boyfriend or husband
that was yeah scottish yeah yeah but i
don't think that ever went through
because
cancer was just getting her and
i'm not sure that ever [ __ ] really
went down that way
that's them right there
i don't know if that camera's picking it
up
yeah
it's just [ __ ] sad
it can get anyone at any time
well yeah
i should go down and get some tests to
[ __ ] look for that [ __ ]
because if you can get it early then you
live
well yeah i mean i told you i had an
uncle that died of it uh at 32
brain tumor yeah by the time they found
it in amber it was just eaten all
throughout her stomach and all her
intestines and it was just there was
nothing they could do it was inoperable
yeah she went through chemo yeah um you
know and she lived like a while like
after after that like after the
diagnosis but
khan okay kind of ozlone friend of mine
her name is jair really from tijuana
mexico
me and him been friends for years online
friends he's asking you a question about
where you would go from i know i'm
trying to i'm trying to catch up okay
bundy jada says uh what is rocky horror
picture show it was a thing people would
go to every year do you really not know
what that is yeah come on
every year we i used to go to it every
week
back in the like late 80s well late 80s
early 90s you should go to it like at
the theater every week and see it
and you'd like do all the audience
participation and stuff come on rocky
horror picture show but he's [ __ ]
seen that
look it up we're not google
khan says jenny which country would you
like to go on vacation to and why a
place you've never gone
oh gosh there's lots of places um
honestly i always wanted to go to
france and i always wanted to go to
italy those are probably like the two
main ones i say france is [ __ ] up
right now
well
okay
yeah anyway out of the two i'd go to
italy
but those are two places that i've
always wanted to go there's like a lot
of places i'd like to go to japan
actually although i don't want to sit on
a plane for that long but
i wouldn't mind going to mexico i had to
go to mexico city go to the god scene
there's tons of places i want to go to
be honest with you but
you know like i said i've been to i've
been to the uk but that's about it
been to england and wales
and that's about it i was planning on
going to italy but i never did get to go
so yeah
that's probably like the first place i
would go but i would like to go to
france too and germany also i'd like to
go to germany mango says the best lineup
of sabbath when dear was the lead singer
well there's a lot of good ozzy when uh
um
there's a lot of good ozzy
in the black sabbath period
they were both really good they were
just very different
very different
bundy jada says i want pink sand and the
swimming tropical swimming pigs i don't
know what that means but you're so
you're like into tropical [ __ ] okay well
i was born and raised in florida which
is
tropical as [ __ ] it's all beaches and
palm trees and [ __ ] like that so i'm
kind of sick of that [ __ ] uh to be
honest when i go on vacation i want
something different i want to go to like
a big city or i want to go to like some
mountains i want to see some snow i want
to see something that i don't usually
see because like i said
i know like most people like oh beaches
and palm trees was like i see that [ __ ]
every day
when i was growing up and it's
cool and everything but when you grow up
around it it's not as enticing
as it is for other people yeah like so
for me i'm just like seeing it
you know what i mean i'm gonna go
somewhere like different they're asking
about the coof shots and [ __ ] now uh
amber and katie were both sick long
before the pandemic kids so coop shots
didn't have anything to do with it
yeah both of them were they've been sick
for years they've been sick for a really
long time yeah they both got struck when
they were young
which is [ __ ] you don't realize you
guys don't realize how young they were
when you knew them
when you know them from the club and
you're hanging out with them
and kaylee was like our little daughter
we would take her out all the time man
we used to pick her up like i said we
used to pick her up every [ __ ] week
like when venue 13 was at that place
that's a chinese restaurant yeah we used
to pick her up every week because she
didn't have a car yeah we used to pick
her up every [ __ ] friday she was this
little bitty goth chick that used to
dress like a [ __ ] kitty cat and she
was just real [ __ ]
cuddly and [ __ ] you know
she's one of those and um well she was
real small yeah a little bitty yeah and
um i'll probably show pictures of kaley
and uh just out of the blue
dying oh [ __ ] intestinal cancer
inoperable
once they found out she was dead about a
year or so later
and her little ex-boyfriend with little
swole who's a friend of mine
they had broken up but once all this
[ __ ] went down he he [ __ ] he'd call
her every day he walked her right up to
the [ __ ] gates he loved her man he
loved her yeah he loved her she
apologized for kind of [ __ ] him over
in a certain way but you know
but she kind of did
she was young and dumb yeah
little swole can be a [ __ ] pain too
but
he did he did care well and she was
mostly
mostly into girls yeah she's mostly into
girls i mean she would sleep with dudes
sometimes but it wasn't really her bag
yeah she was mostly into girls let me
see if i could see i mean she was
married for a while her i mean her wife
uh laura was actually like pretty
awesome yeah i liked her
so
yeah that was a that was a shitty
situation and like honestly i was
thinking about it the other day because
i was like [ __ ] man that's who we're
talking about that was kaylee
and that's pretty much what she looked
like she looked just like that when she
died yeah pretty much i mean she was 34
i think yeah yeah but she looked real
young she was very very small
um yeah we're talking about a little
tiny like four times i mean i'm short
yeah but she was like super short she
was like way shorter than me she was
yeah four foot ten four four eleven
something like that yeah she's tiny half
mexican yeah tiny girl mexican irish
girl
but i was just thinking about
how many people
i don't you know why i thought of this
because our friend imani
um
she said oh the other day i was like on
facebook and i was like clearing out my
friends list or whatever as one has to
do like on facebook every now and then
and she's like while i was doing it i
realized how many people on my friends
list had died yeah
and i was just kind and we're
i mean we're old but we're not that old
and a lot of the people that we've known
that have died have been like young
yeah which is weird that's all of us
right there a few years ago that's back
when i had hair
back when you had hair yeah
how long ago was that
six seven years six seven years
something yeah that's kaley up front
look how little she is and i'm a short
little [ __ ] yeah i'm only five foot two
five foot three yeah james is wearing
high and i'm wearing platforms right
there so yeah and okay so is kaylee
though katie's wearing platforms too
remember she we gave her a bunch of
little platforms and shoes and [ __ ]
and
katie was probably about 4
ten
if that if that yeah she was any time
she was a tiny person
but it's just i don't know it's just
weird that
and like i said i know we're getting
like i'm
i'll be 50 in september yeah
but
nowadays that's not that old but i it
kind of occurs to me that a lot of
people that we've known that have died
have died young younger than us yeah i
mean
the weird thing is like [ __ ]
our age are still [ __ ] kicking yeah
we go out
and a lot of the people that we know
some of them are older than we are and
they're still going out and drinking and
[ __ ] doing what i'm dancing and [ __ ]
like that we know a lot of people our
age and older that are still going out
but like a lot of younger people
not super young but in between like in
the 30s
yeah
dying
weird it's weird it can come at any time
chad that's why i talk well yeah i know
i know yeah well yeah i understand that
yeah
the captain says life is full of kittens
full of loss
all we the living can do is enjoy the
moment that yes exactly you enjoy
everything to the maximum you die like a
[ __ ] valk like a [ __ ] valkyrie if
you're a woman and you die like a
[ __ ] viking if you're a man just go
headlong into it because it's all just
temporary anyway it's all just temporary
and we just join all those other people
in the past that you know what i mean
it's just
it's a natural way of things like yoda
says that's just the way the force
yeah no one can resist it i mean it's
not fair nothing's fair no such thing as
fair no there's not grandpa says it's
also not fair that you live forever
because you have to [ __ ] make room
for new things
now you can live longer
if you extend your life out to a few
million years it's still not forever
it's it's just longer
maybe one day that day will come but not
now we don't have the technology i kind
of wonder about that like would i
be into
living forever or living like a million
years essentially like a million years
i'm not sure
it would depend it would depend on a lot
of things it's like look is somebody
gonna give me enough money to like live
comfortably for all that time or i might
have been struggling all that time
because if i'm struggling all the time
then [ __ ] it i'll just i'd rather die
um
but if i could live in luxury that whole
entire time and could like kind of do
whatever i wanted yeah i would totally
live forever
okay and i wouldn't get lonely or
anything like that because
like i said i'm i'm very happy in my own
company
we got a big we got a big crowd in there
people
super chats people now we gotta like
talk about some exciting ships yes yeah
that's right
chad send some questions said i've
recently lost a good friend age 51 drank
himself to death man that's [ __ ] up
and honestly when we did the show
wednesday night about bob ross i didn't
realize yeah he died when he was 52
of cancer
uh lymphoma and i was like [ __ ] man
that's only like
like i said i'll be 50 in
late september
so i'm like that's only two years older
than me
which is crazy
but man getting old is like [ __ ]
weird it's [ __ ] weird and to be
honest with you i'm just like i'm kind
of scared i'm kind of hoping
i mean i feel fine
um
you know uh but
[ __ ] i don't i don't have any insurance
i don't have any anything
uh plus i'm not a big fan of like going
to doctors especially i don't like going
to doctors unless i feel like i'm super
dying like you know what i mean i have
gone a few times when it's just like
okay something is really really clearly
very wrong but most of the time i'm just
kind of like bad
it's all right i'm not you know it's
fine
so i'm kind of like
getting to the age now
i was thinking about it this morning
actually because i know so maybe this is
tmi but
last night um
i woke up i think four times four times
five times something like that a bunch
of times i woke up a bunch of times last
night because i really had to pee like
really bad
and so i was like this isn't cool like
why do i keep waking up every hour or
two hours like to go pee this is not
normal
and i was like
i wonder do i have diabetes i'm like oh
[ __ ] i better not have diabetes because
i don't have any insurance and i can't
like [ __ ] deal with that but diabetes
does run in my family like my
grandfather had it my dad is borderline
so
they used to check me for it
back when i used to have insurance but i
don't have i have an insurance for like
five years plus
and uh so i'm just kind of like winging
it just hoping everything will work out
for the best hoping everything will work
out for the best for what
uh because i don't have any insurance oh
you gotta work out
that's what i'm saying
just just hoping everything will work
out granthar says dust in the wind my
friends
yeah all we are is just in the wind
oh my god
tammy said my son died of a heart
problem at age 11
and my gram lived until she was three
months away from 102.
life is weird yeah there's really not
i kind of feel like that's probably why
i came to like atheism as a very young
age because i'm like look there's no
rhyme or reason to this
um it doesn't have anything to do with
whether you're a good person or a bad
person it doesn't
care whether you're a child or whether
you're an old person
there's really not yeah you can do some
things to
stave off certain things yes you can but
on the whole you're kind of like uh at
the whim of
nature which is completely indifferent
to your wants and well i hope that's so
because
i favor more of my mother's side of the
family and my grandparents on that side
of the family basically lived to be
about a hundred
so hopefully i'll [ __ ] kind of hope
honestly i'm kind of hoping that i lean
into like my mom's side as well because
even though
my mom's side of the family tends to
uh being overweight obviously but they
do tend to live quite a long time
my maternal grandmother is still alive
she's in her 90s
she's had a stroke um she's not doing
that great right now but like i said
she's
in her 90s uh and she's still alive and
she's still
coherent she still
has all her faculties as far as i know
so there's that my mom who is
let's see how old is she i'm almost so i
guess she'd be 67 68. she had me when
she was 18. um
she's actually like in pretty good shape
still uh like i said we tend toward
being overweight like on my mom's side
of the family but they do tend to live a
long time
although the males on that side
not so much because my uncle who is not
that much older than my mom
has early onset alzheimer's
and
so they have been taking care
of my uncle at the same time they're
taking care of my grandma like his
mother
uh because he's
apparently so far gone i haven't seen
him in a long time but he's apparently
so far gone that they're like having to
take care of him and her at the same
time and apparently she's like way more
coherent than he is because he's like
out there
i mean alzheimer's no [ __ ] joke
i mean
probably not so bad for the person that
has it but bad for everybody else that
has to like care for them which you know
no i'm just saying but well i'm not
laughing at you i'm laughing on my
conscience what do you think i can see
tom is an elder in an apocalyptic
village in the near future the near
future was going to be up how can i be
an elder in the near future the deer
i can only be an elder in the far future
i'm not old enough to be an elder in the
near future
all right so what do you guys uh
what's on the mind you guys have any
[ __ ] uh cases you want us to talk
about
any questions about [ __ ] shows we did
in the past
um but now is the time probably we need
to talk about
something that's relative to the [ __ ]
13 o'clock in the show
like uh
now
look at pokey look at pokemon no she's
back there i go over there look at the
cat and the cat is looking
why do you hide she's up there hiding up
with all the [ __ ] little the little
stuffed
she looks at me like like what
yeah
she looked at me just like that yeah i
don't know about you but i'm getting
hungry how long have you been streaming
three three three hours no two hours and
20 minutes two hours and 20 minutes
that's all okay so in a half hour it'll
be a [ __ ] three hours yeah calm down
okay
not calming down we don't we don't need
to calm down i'm just saying i'm just
saying [ __ ] i'm getting hungry are you
getting hungry
well a bit i got all kinds of food
downstairs okay make a omelette or
something
with gravy
don't put gravy on the chicken you want
graveyard like southern gravy i like
gravy on it no that's i don't know i
don't i don't want all that gloppy stuff
you're like gloppy
i don't like black food
want like a laughing stuff on my face
okay mr 88 says one of my grandmothers
worked full-time until she was 90 and
only retired then because she was forced
to buy her family my great-grandma was
kind of like that i mean she lived alone
until she was in her 90s
and
then like my grandparents like my
grandmother's
well there's like her half sister i
don't remember who it was but it's like
they were kind of like yeah you can't
live by yourself anymore because what if
you fall and break your hip and she was
like really bad she was like adamant
that you were not putting media home but
they did they put her in a home then
what happened to her
she committed suicide no [ __ ] really
yeah she shouldn't have put her in the
house she slashed her wrist [ __ ]
long ways she left her [ __ ] at the
house she told them yeah she said i want
to live alone she wanted to live
independently she did she had her little
garden she had her little house
she had her whole thing and
you know
okay
oscar's asking wants me to talk about
the el paso walmart shooting of 2019
with 22 cats oh we were gonna do like a
whole show about that right
okay well i don't have all the
information i just remember the [ __ ]
that was happening around that time
and that [ __ ] just sounded fishy as [ __ ]
you know
um
i don't know who it was it's just
some crazy
some crazy
we should do a whole show about that
right i think somebody asked about
us doing a show yeah
i think i wrote it down before but i'll
write it down again he wasn't from there
he moved there he he moved down there
from a northern state
to do it you know he drove all the way
down there to go do it
and it was almost kind of like it was uh
some kind of a political
thing
but it didn't have anything to do with
texas
he was trying to say that he was trying
to de-mexicanify
texas as if that's possible
texas was always half mexican
class you didn't take happiness history
class what [ __ ] this dude talking about
it was originally conceived
texas was originally conceived from day
one between the business verger business
merger to powerful [ __ ] cattle
ranching families one of them was irish
american the other most [ __ ] met was
mexican
from day one
spanish mexican
it's so weird to me that like people
talk about right when you say mexican
that's some i grew up in brazil all
right i know the [ __ ] truth about
central and south america it's all a
mixed population
and like in mexico was part spanish at
the time because you know since the
1500s there was there was spanish in
there
and um they interbred almost instantly
you know cortez's wife
was
mexican indian
and there he had sons with her
that ended up doing things
and um just
the more you get towards big cities in
mexico the more spanish they kind of
look
it was always a mixed population even in
mexico
so you're talking about
the creation of mexico was a merger
of
irish and british
and
indian and spanish all in that place
down there those those were other times
and for some reason they got people up
north that don't know the south very
well
and texas is part of the south but up
north and maybe out west
they think that there was racial purity
in america
in all of america since day one no it
was always mixed always
people were marrying each other from day
one
it's just what happens well as we
mentioned earlier everything is always a
lot more complicated right they're
trying to simplify
and then and like i get
why they do that like like i said you
know in school curriculums it's like
look we got to cover this that the other
thing like fine they'll like just
scan over stuff but
everything is a lot more complicated
yeah even even like uh the stories about
american slavery have been
oversimplified
about how well the civil war was because
the south supported slavery no not
really
the
most slavery that was happening in the
south the most slavery happening in what
you would call dixie or the southern
parts of the united states was in
mississippi
mississippi was one-third black
and two-thirds caucasian
but half of the counties in mississippi
had banned slavery it was never agreed
upon even before the civil war
if you were to ask people in the north
about the civil war they would say well
the south was fighting for slavery if
you were to ask people in the south what
the civil war was about in those days
they would say it's us defending our
homes
it hadn't from the point of view of the
people in the south they didn't really
see it that way because most people in
the south didn't agree with slavery
it didn't
most white people didn't want it
and they didn't want it for different
reasons some was religious reasons they
thought it was wrong other ones didn't
like it because it was putting them out
of the job
you couldn't compete against slave
plantations
you just couldn't
they just dominated the entire [ __ ]
states you just couldn't compete against
them because they could have very low
operating costs
so just like it was just like back in
ancient rome
the roman empire had promised all these
damn veterans
of the [ __ ] war against [ __ ] um
what was a [ __ ] place down there in
north africa
with hannibal and all those guys [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] not peloponnesian wars
anyway
rome had promised all these roman
veterans
land farmland
as part of their separation pay for
their duty but that never happened
because the roman elites had [ __ ]
imported
german slaves
into and they gave their and they bought
up all the land
so rome was being
supported by
german-powered slave plantations
which suppressed the economy
and made roman people poor
and from that a bunch of populist
uprisings happened which [ __ ] led to
the [ __ ]
julius caesar allow people to
have a thing where they can have workers
without having to pay them right so
obviously people are gonna jump right in
yeah slate slave the slave systems
always depress the economy they depress
[ __ ]
money and make people poor it's about
poverty
and uh they couldn't get it the ruling
elite couldn't get away with that
so eventually i mean they can for a time
they can only get away for a certain
amount of time but after but after a
while they can't get away so what they
do is they [ __ ]
tried to replace slaves with illegal
aliens and illegal immigrants which is
exactly the same concept it's about rich
people getting richer and depressing
the [ __ ] economy so poor people stay
poor
um
there's got to be another way out of it
all right but it's that same similar
concept rich people are always trying to
get rich
the only way they can do that is to keep
[ __ ] labor costs down eventually
they're going to [ __ ] us all because
they're going to replace even those
illegal aliens in those illegal images
they will replace them with robots
eventually yeah i mean like people that
are rich like they don't actually want
to do any work themselves
well they want to sell a product that
costs them nothing to make
yeah that's what it gets down to but
they can't make it themselves
because you have to make things in
volume sure so you need robots
eventually so the people that make it
right yeah
so it's just uh
divide and conquer strategies have
always been around the british i'm not
[ __ ] around the british some of the i
have a lot of british ancestors but the
british invented divide and conquer
strategies with india
and in the united states too they were
also doing it during the revolutionary
wars
if you're in power you divide your
enemies
and you conquer them okay you get them
to hate each other based upon race
religion creed sex or whatever
when you see propaganda that divides
the intent is to conquer because they do
not want union because if you get
together you'll [ __ ] depose them just
like that [ __ ] pixar movie about we
gotta knock these ants down because we
gotta [ __ ] know one by one if we let
them rise up they'll [ __ ] overthrow
us that's what they're doing
okay
[ __ ] what's it called what was that
movie about the ants that that pixar did
was it bug's life i think so bug's life
yeah that's what that's what that's what
it is well there were a couple that came
out at the same time i can't remember
which one was the picture um
you're little people i'm little people
we are little people they're just trying
to make money
they will do or say anything to stay in
power
just remember that right and wrong have
nothing to do with it
nothing
and i used to believe in a left-right
dichotomy and [ __ ] republicans and
democrats they're all bad they're all
bad
the [ __ ] republicans are [ __ ] too
danny rolling goes face says how about
the 1967 st petersburg florida case of
mary rieser in her case of spontaneous
combustion i kind of feel like we did a
show
about spontaneous oh yeah yeah i know
all about spontaneous combustion and
talked about that because
back in the old days i used to have a
poster
of that
from
the believe it or not like ripley's
believe it or not thing because they was
like a poster of like the it was the
foot that was left there i'm pretty sure
we talked about that on that show but
that was a long time ago right khan says
whatever happened to episode 100 it was
hilarious i was searching for it and
it's not there anymore probably i know
well i have to look okay which one was
that about con i don't even remember
what the hundred thousand maybe maybe
youtube took it down or maybe was that
the one was that the one that shawna and
them were on i don't know
i don't know i don't remember i have to
look
um
what were you just talking about bundy
says did you do jim jones yes we did we
did a show about jim jones yeah last
year i think i think it was like
spontaneous human combustion used to
trip me the [ __ ] out i thought there was
something to it but then i saw a
reenactment of what was happening to
those bodies and it makes perfect sense
the body is converted into a candle
you can take a
pig carcass and put it on top of a
carpet and then throw a rug over the pig
carcass and then you can take a lighter
and [ __ ] hit that pig carcass with it
get that fat burning and it'll burn like
a candle
it'll make smoke and it'll do all the
effects and everything
and the body will be totally consumed
and not set the room on fire because the
flames never get high with only a few
inches and it never really gets that hot
but it's being concentrated just in one
small area and it burns like a candle
and that's what's happening to those
bodies from the human combustion cases
they're falling asleep with a cigarette
in their hand or dying with this of a
heart attack with a cigarette in their
hand
and it starts a fire and the fire starts
very small and what's funny is that the
flames not only they're not very high
the body is not burning all over it at
once
the fire spreads through it kind of like
embers
you know the fire spreads through the
body slowly burning a little by little
at a time
and it causes the soot around the top of
the
ceiling and causes certain things to
melt like a candle but it doesn't melt
this and that because it never really
got that hot in that room
all right but that but the bones
reduced to ash
like it was thousands and thousands of
degrees it wasn't it was kind of a low
temperature fire
they've done it
they've got the [ __ ] on camera when you
see it happening you're going yeah
that's what it is that's what it is
it's not something we're just
all at once and the person is [ __ ]
consumed in flames and vanishes that's
not what it is
it takes hours
it's six seven hours of it's just
sitting there smoldering it's freaky
looking but
yeah it's not as freaky looking now when
you see it
and then the flames are they never
really even get above six inches high
you know and it's only in certain parts
of the body just spreading across to it
so it's not even very impressive to see
when you see it you immediately
recognize what kind of fire it is
you go oh i've seen that all the time
the campfires
grantor is asking some more random
questions
would you ever work as correctional
officers
no no no i wouldn't mind doing forensic
work yeah
like after the fact
um i wouldn't mind doing that
but
correctional officers as in dealing with
actual people and dealing with yeah no
thanks no thanks
um
but like i said i wouldn't mind doing
like some forensic science kind of work
i'd be into that actually but
otherwise top gun 2
must see or must avoid
gonna say okay we saw the trailer if
you're talking about top gun
maverick which is coming out later this
month
i saw the trailer for it and it looked
um
well i'm not a big fan of the first top
gun movie because it's not really my
kind of thing
but
this one looked i was like well
this looks like more of the same this
looks like the top gun movie from the
80s
so
okay
and like tom i'm sure wants to see it so
i will probably end up seeing it it
looks pretty cool it looked pretty cool
it's not my preferred genre obviously um
and everybody knows i'm not the hugest
fan of tom cruise not least because he's
a scientologist but there's other
reasons too
um
but it looks okay it looks okay it looks
kind of like the same tone as the first
one which is fine
it's fine
so we will probably see it at some point
because i kind of feel like tom wants to
see it
so we probably will
best songs for boom boom time
oh
uh
uh okay
grantham's is asking about top gun too
like the new top guys we haven't seen
assuming no he says mess must see or
must avoid that oh i must see well for
us let's see how we got to see that one
well for you yeah i'm just kind of like
yeah it looks like the old one which
like i said i'm not a big fan of but
okay it's tom cruise movie and this is
supposed to be one of two he's gonna
smirk his way through it it'll it'll be
fine see how jenny does
all right
it looks cool i understand tom i
understand tom i understand how he is
okay
it's the it's the it's the dao of tom
yeah i'm one other people named tom
right that's right you guys have a whole
like thing going on
there's a short white guy
named tom thing okay
it's a short way it's a very specific
demographic yeah
guarantee you're part of me [ __ ] tom
right if i had to meet tom in the right
circumstances the short guy thing would
kick in and it'd be all right and i want
to talk to him about certain things and
not ask him about scientology if you
want to talk about it we talk about
motorcycles you talk about movies
[ __ ] i think me and tom probably get
along all right probably oh i don't
doubt it i probably get a lot i don't
doubt it all right because because i'm
not real superficial when it comes to i
understand the hype that was behind the
tom cruise accusations
i'm trying to see it clearly all right
and trying to put myself in his shoes
i'm trying to empathize but the thing
about tom cruise though since you said
the word superficial yeah is that to me
he seems nothing but superficial like
there's nothing behind that no i think
there is something behind that wait that
maybe but it doesn't seem like it to me
and that's really
off-putting graham and i we came from
the same drama school he's doing a
[ __ ]
he's being in character he's doing the
time i get that like i've seen other
actors do that but i still but i still
feel that there's something else behind
that tom cruise i don't feel that he's
in from he's in his groove and he's
delivering to the camera that's his job
okay so
but anyway getting better i was getting
to
tom cruise's career really
was built on top gun
so the way tom is i understand he he
demands excellence from himself
if there's gonna be
a revisit
to that character it's gotta be a magnus
open you know
magnum magnum opus i'm drinking i'm
drinking yeah matt it's gonna be a
matter of two but
he's gonna have to [ __ ] come back
and blow everybody out of the water this
movie should have been this movie should
have been released a couple of years ago
but he
he he said no we're not gonna release
this during the pandemic after okay so
and they tweaked a bunch of [ __ ]
i have a feeling it's gonna be great
i have a feeling it's gonna be great
just saying we'll see
i mean the trailer
i mean it looks pretty good but it
looked like the first one
looks like people would want yeah and
like i said i'm not a huge fan of the
first one i was just kind of like yeah i
was already i liked the first one the
first one was a fantastic recruitment
tool for the air force a lot of people
[ __ ] joined the air force because of
that all right
um and it wouldn't surprise me if cia
was involved in that or air force maybe
coughed up money to help that as well
yeah they probably did they probably did
they weren't above that
i've actually heard guys from russia
say that top gun movie at that time
increased
[ __ ] recruitment in russia
that's how they like that movie imagine
watching a movie and then saying i'm
going to sign my whole entire life away
because of a movie no
that's not your whole life it's only a
couple years well you know what i mean
it's only a couple years of a year the
next few years of my life well it's a
young guy because he's a
you're a young man living at home and
you don't want to [ __ ] be around for
your hometown you want to go out and see
the world and have an adventure and
there's a bunch of different ways you're
going to go all right that movie gets
you to go i'm going to join my air force
and my nation
now did they end up being pilots [ __ ] no
they didn't have the math skills or the
[ __ ]
you can't just jump into the cockpit of
f-16 you're gonna have to be a scholarly
man they don't want any dumb ass kidding
no you've got to be a [ __ ] damn
scholar [ __ ] know everything about
avionics and [ __ ] mathematics and at
least back in those days i don't know if
the standards are that high now but
back in those days they were uh [ __ ]
scholars
uh to be you had to know your [ __ ]
before you did ever put you in a [ __ ]
cockpit of a [ __ ]
f-14 tomcat or a [ __ ]
it's like do you know how much tv
and it cost too much goddamn money
you know and um so but
they joined and ended up being the
crewmen that [ __ ] strapped the bombs
on the bottom and kept [ __ ] [ __ ]
running and fixing computers which is is
just as honorable they need an air crews
to do all that stuff and they have fun
too and um actually i think
tom cruise's character was uh not air
force but navy okay
because the f-14 was it was a navy naval
aircraft
and the navy needed those kind of guys
and um my dad was in the navy he was on
the uss yorktown as an electrician and
it's just a floating [ __ ] city you
know of dudes trying to keep the [ __ ]
aircraft carrier moving it's and in
those days that was a hell of a [ __ ]
weapon system i don't think it is now
hypersonic weapons like what the
russians have to [ __ ] blow that
aircraft carrier out of the water hasn't
happened yet
but if [ __ ] china invades sucking
taiwan and we get in the middle of that
that'd be the first time we're going to
see a [ __ ] aircraft carrier
battlegroup go to the bottom of the
ocean well i wouldn't get involved in
that
aircraft carriers and aircraft carrier
battle groups are only to be used
against the third world you go against
the first world country you're gonna get
your ass [ __ ] sunk
expensive weapons will sink you right
down to the bottom all right so
but
i think tom cruise probably did real
well on that movie
i got a feeling that that's gonna be a
good move the the fallouts not thoughts
the uh the [ __ ] what was uh mission
mission impossible that with that last
one [ __ ]
rogue nation and fallout nothing they
were great i thought they were good i
did like mission impossible every bit as
good as the new james bond movies
now each one although i can't remember a
single thing about it yeah they go by so
quick
[Laughter]
you know like one two and three they
were all movies of their times but the
later ones they're just like the new
james bond movies i thought they were
great
ethan hunt
good character
mr 88 says first true crime cases jen
have you read the killer of little
shepherds i have not
uh worth a read and a show as i doubt
any of your viewers are familiar with
the case and it is very interesting okay
i'm gonna write that down because
i will look that up later on
and maybe we can do a show about it
because that sounds really good i have
not read it
but most people in there are saying that
[ __ ] it is a must-see gotta see
maverick mango badger rebecca dunn yeah
i think so too
i think i mean we're gonna see it yeah i
wrote it
down uh granters also asked i tried to
answer this question but i couldn't
think of anything one of his uh last
questions was best songs for boom boom
time
what who's who's asking this grab theirs
oh i don't know you don't need music to
have sex too
yeah i don't really get that i wasn't
really like i was never like a real big
like music dev sexy person no this [ __ ]
just go overtakes you
and you're like i'm gonna have to get
some of this
and then the woman's gonna be like wow
okay all right
that's how it goes yeah that's usually
how the woman because uh yeah all right
okay all right if you if you yeah if we
have to
yeah yeah
y'all don't want to know like what kind
of music i'd like one of them yeah
it'd be like holy con says that [ __ ]
young guns three is coming out
i didn't even know that wade did they
even know there was i didn't
yeah i saw the first one the first one
was good
i didn't know they made the second one
though
which is what i know
strawberry says the army just released a
new recruiting ad for people wanting to
join psyops yet
yeah the uh the the
the [ __ ] armed forces of the united
states is a [ __ ]
joke yeah that's all has been [ __ ] you
want some more of this okay sure why not
yeah you're gonna find out real soon the
united states is no longer a superpower
it doesn't have what it takes anymore
it's been long gone people today are
imagining the army of
the first and the second gulf war that
situation is gone that was us
back i was in during the first gulf war
world-class military
just beating the [ __ ] out of a
third-rate [ __ ] middle eastern
[ __ ] country all right they were big
but third rate all right we just [ __ ]
them up and people got real used to that
like they thought that was the normal
situation that is not the normal
situation and that first-rate army is
long gone grounded dust in afghanistan
after 10 years
what you got in there now
no no no no
all right
peter says ever see the long list of
popular movies that remember the
oversight of the pentagon uh i can
imagine that is a very long list
honestly
i've even seen seen some like shitty ass
low budget movies on mystery science
theater
that were made with the cooperation of
various
united states armed forces
i'm thinking mainly of one called what
was it called the starfighters
and that was
very very clearly an air force uh
recruitment movie
and it's
terrible but
what are you gonna do
it's hilarious like on the show
but
on its own it's terrible
because they had no idea how to make
like a
movie they thought they were way more
interesting than they were that was
their mistake
uh grifter says grandparent became a cop
because he watched hill street blues as
a teenager okay well i'm not hating i'm
not hating i'm just saying
i don't know i never really knew
i don't think i ever got any ideas from
like media the only thing i ever wanted
to be ever
was
a writer
a horror writer because i loved scary
[ __ ] from
birth i don't even like remember a time
when i didn't like scary [ __ ]
i honestly can't remember a time
when i learned to read the first thing i
wanted to read was ghost stories and
[ __ ] about witches and [ __ ] like that
so
i can't remember a time when i didn't
want to read scary [ __ ]
so
i mean there were
obviously writers that inspired me like
when i was
11 12 years old
the first time i was like oh i want to i
want to write horror i'm going to write
horror stories that's all i wanted to do
or make horror movies or do horror
makeup i wanna do something like having
to do with that
but when i read
i think the the catalyst i think was
reading
clive barker the first time i read clive
barker because i'd read stephen king
prior to that i was really into that
like in junior high and [ __ ] like that
pet cemetery i [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
the shining dead zone i read all that
[ __ ]
but then and i was like yeah this is
awesome i want to do that one day but
then i read
clyde barker i think it was like the
first volume of like the books of blood
i checked it out of the library
the first time i read clyde barker's
books of blood that
blew my [ __ ] mind
i read that and i was like
holy [ __ ]
this is what i want to do this i want to
write like this [ __ ]
dude i didn't even know that much about
clyde barker at that time
but when i because i had bred stephen
king prior i've read edgar allan poe
i've read hp hp lovecraft all that [ __ ]
i read all that stuff when i was a
little kid
but breeding clyde barker was
the linchpin i think
because i was like i i began to see
the possibilities
you know what i'm saying
you know
and i watched a lot of horror movies
when i was a kid so you saw like edgar
allan poe [ __ ] like hp love crap [ __ ]
like you'd seen all of that but clive
barker
had his own [ __ ] thing going on
and i was just kind of like holy [ __ ]
like that's possible
and like that kind of like inspired me i
was like i want to write like that
[ __ ] i want to do that
and that really like
kind of like cemented even though i'd
wanted to be a horror writer since i can
remember
but that was what cemented it and i was
maybe like 11
12 years old when i first read books of
blood that [ __ ] blew my mind blew my
[ __ ] mind
let's see
coming up on three hours i think
yeah okay
i'm getting hungry
mango says books of blood are amazing
they are honestly i still remember this
many years later
that [ __ ] short story
in the hills the cities
what a [ __ ] great story that was look
at that what is she doing
pookie is over there by my curtains
she was just sitting there like and she
just like he's holding her eyes she was
like with her little like back
her little drumstick
i call him her drumsticks for a little
bit trying to cover her eyes up shut up
she's like over there by the curtains
like curled up oh well she likes like
listening to our voices i think
yeah but yeah i still wish that somebody
would make a movie
out of in the hills the cities
because the first time that is still
i mean midnight me train's great too and
like that movie was like pretty good
but
the first time i read that i think that
was like the the thing that like caused
me to be like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] because
i was like how did he even think of that
in the hills the cities if you haven't
read it is this story about these two
guys who are like on vacation and they
stumble acro i think it's in eastern
europe somewhere and they stumble across
these two towns
and i don't know i don't remember if
it's every year or like some time
every
so often
these two towns like go to war with each
other but in a really weird way every
town like every able-bodied person in
that town
they all strap themselves together
into one big
person
you know what i mean like a big monster
and the other town does that too so it's
just kind of like this big being that's
all these humans that are all strapped
together and then they all fight each
other
and i was just like that story like the
way he described it was just like
amazing and i was just kind of like holy
[ __ ] they really need to make that into
a [ __ ] movie i'm amazed they haven't
done that
amazed
so much but the thing about it is that
clyde barker stuff everybody talks about
like stephen king adaptations
of which there have been
a bajillion you know some of them are
awesome some of them are mediocre some
of them are terrible
clive barker adaptations thinner on the
ground
but
i feel like
i don't know man like climb barker's
imagination
is
in a lot of ways like too big to be
contained by
visuals
i feel like his stuff is best approached
in its original form
um i know he's a visual artist as well
because he's a painter and his paintings
are actually like quite cool but
i don't know i i kind of feel like most
other than hellraiser and other than
like a few other movies that they've
made of his stuff i like i did like
midnight may train i like some other
stuff that they've made from his stuff
but
it does seem like a lot of the movies
that they make from are just like not
they're good but they're like not as
good as his
pros
and some of his [ __ ] like
a magica or like we world or something
like that it's like
i don't even know like you can make that
into a movie but it just would fall
short
because i kind of feel like his stuff
is so like pure imagination you know
what i mean it's like if you try to like
put it on film it wouldn't
look as good as like you were imagining
it like when i read weave world
i was thinking to myself man this would
make an awesome movie but then i'm like
maybe it wouldn't because
it wouldn't be as good as like what i'm
imagining like in my head because what
you imagine is like this amazing [ __ ]
and they're just not going to be able to
like show that
so i don't know i don't know
um is this going to be a 5 hour episode
granthar's into the end
well tom seems like he's already getting
bored yeah
i'm just trying to get something to eat
i'm hungry
dj maniac says and magicka was super
slow i remember like really liking a
magica honestly one of the clyde barker
ones that i liked a lot that a lot of
people don't talk about is cold heart
canyon
i really liked cold hard candy because i
like that like that old hollywood
kind of [ __ ] do it i liked that but
weave world probably my favorite
other than like his short stories
because i kind of feel like his short
stories were like his uh strength you
know what i'm saying yeah
dj maniac says i went from layman
to king to barker which was ages 8 to
14.
you started out with uh richard layman
that's pretty hardcore because a lot of
his stuff is just like straight up smut
i kind of feel like
at least most of the stuff is that i've
read
and i'd be interested because he wrote a
lot of books but
richard layman he's passed away now if
you haven't already richard layman i've
reviewed like um i reviewed come out
tonight and maybe one other one like on
my channel
or on my show
richard layman was really into
i kind of feel like a lot of his stuff
was like adolescent fantasies like
adolescent boy fantasies
like hey what would happen
if i'm 17 a teenage boy and i found this
woman that had been raped and left for
dead
and
found at the bottom of this overpass
and now she's all injured
and i can
either rescue her or i can do whatever
the hell i want with her so i kind of
feel like it it's it operates in that
gray area so a lot of richard layman's
stuff is very
i find it juvenile
but it's also like really really
entertaining i think i also uh i also
reviewed one of his other ones what was
it called
body rides
i found this book body rides in
uh
like a secondhand bookstore
i had read some richard lamo before but
i never read that one
that book
that book is crazy as [ __ ]
it's almost kind of like
i don't know like go watch my review of
it
um because it was pretty funny but that
book
it's barely a horror book most of his
[ __ ] is like smut but then there's like
horror toward the end kind of
i he gets lumped in with
splatter punk authors which i guess he
kind of is like with jack
the ketchum and all that kind of stuff
and douglas clegg and people like that
but
most of his stuff is like just
is smut pretty much but if that's what
you're looking for then you know that's
fine that's fine
you should do a cooking show again says
blair dude we haven't done that a long
time you want to do meatballs do you eat
balls yeah that's what we didn't do
that we need to do that's easy
yeah but not everybody knows that though
because the thing about it is that
there's only a couple kinds you can do
italian type meatballs american
meatballs and swedish meatballs which
are similar uh just that the spicing is
different some have
different kinds of
different kinds of bread involved
someone's breadcrumbs other than it's
just a sweet meatballs just [ __ ]
regular like white
wonder breads
that's been soaked in milk
that's the old school way there's a
bunch of ways where you can fake that
because that's too much work um
how do you feel about the beef versus
pork mixture most of them are a mixture
of the two that's what i'm saying um
because i kind of feel like a lot of
people that don't know a lot about
making meatballs we'll just make them
out of beef but that's what they have
it's usually like it's usually like a
beef and pork yeah or mixed sausage
sausage there's a bunch of things that
you can do you can also do like beef and
beef and ground turkey
sure you can fake you can fake it that
way um well ground turkey is like pretty
cheap if you buy it like those little
chubs yeah yeah yeah so sometimes you
can cut it with turkey
to get more mass and then you're gonna
add different kinds of
breadcrumbs all right uh or just like i
said soaked
pieces of bread that have been soaked in
[ __ ] milk
which which i don't understand why they
did it that way there's another ways to
do you could you could soak breadcrumbs
in milk um but
it's a you know swedish meatballs the
genus of that genesis of that [ __ ] at
least here in the united states is 60s
mortgage board [ __ ]
cooking
which is something you'd get it down
on a buffet table
and uh
those cooks weren't that good back in
those days most of them weren't and they
were dealing with limited
selection of
components so it could have been that
they didn't have dried pre-made bread
crumbs so they were trying to make them
you know
could be too that their audience was
older people so they're like we can't
put any spice in that well they weren't
old at that time
but they were yeah you say they were
older generations back then that's what
i'm saying like old people now
yeah we don't like a lot of spices
which i get it
like nowadays not because i don't want
to but because
i'll get heartburn but
so maybe that's the same i'm also not
sure how swedish those are i mean i i
have to [ __ ] check the history i
don't know ikea sells that so and that's
a swedish company it's where i think
swedish meatballs
yeah
every ikea store has a cafe and they're
famous for their swedish meat the fact
they're probably more famous for their
swedish meatballs they're for their
furniture i've never had them i go to
the
what are they do they serve them off
flat noodles or they serve on potatoes
oh i don't know i haven't been to an
ikea in a long time there's an ikea in
orlando but i don't remember where it is
because i bought some bookshelves there
like uh many years ago probably like 9
or ten years ago but there's one around
here someplace
that's kind of like their whole thing
rebecca says they're amazing but what do
they serve them with rebecca
on noodles or they serve them on rice a
lot of people really like them i usually
just eat them with [ __ ] instant
mashed potatoes i don't think that i
ever ate ikea's swedish meatballs you've
made swedish meatballs which were
delicious
um they're good but i don't think i've
ever eaten them but i've only been in
ikea like maybe three or four times in
my entire life um [ __ ] traditionally
it's a 50 50 50 mix swedish meatballs
are a 50 50 mixture of ground beef
ground pork
so a lot of times i don't have the pork
so it's just going to be a beef
you know
but
it doesn't make a big difference
they're just meatballs
they're just me they're just meatballs
but like i said
the mix of the meat and like the spices
that you put in them it like it does
make a big difference in what they taste
like all right it looks like a lot of
people are [ __ ] filtering out lily's
going contest that's the show for you
tom the joy the meatball yeah like bob
ross yeah
he's tom's checking out i'm checking out
so i guess we're going yeah well
all right the show's been going on for
about three hours and [ __ ] people are
starting to filter out exactly
throughout go ahead and shut it down you
know we don't we don't want to [ __ ]
outstay our welcome all right yeah been
a while since we had a super chat
but it's just saying just saying
got that time and i'll make it something
to eat we'll be back on sunday right
either
we'll go see fire starter tomorrow or we
won't if we don't then we'll just like
watch a random ass movie yeah if we
don't we'll go to the club tomorrow if
we don't
or we'll watch a random mass movie and
like we'll see about that
we'll see we'll be back on sunday
afternoon talking about some some [ __ ]
we don't know what find out when you
find out
so thanks for hanging out with us on
this friday evening and we will see you
guys on
sunday evening
bye